we got some big news out of the Red Sea
and Yemen the US and the UK have
launched massive retaliatory strikes the
Rebels the rebels in in the region were
blocking the Red Sea over Israel's
actions in the Gaza war and now the US
and the UK have entered this conflict
substantially there were already
concerns based on iran-backed militias
attacking American bases in Iraq so the
concern here whenever we get stories
like this is that the conflict is
escalating towards oh I'm going to say
it some type of World War III type
situation I know I went a little light
on that one and the reason why is people
think World War III means big superpower
fights big superpower but right now
we're looking at Venezuela potentially
going to invade Guyana we've got
conflict in Europe already there's some
reports off the defto Luke on this one
Sweden is preparing for war because
they're afraid of what Russia's going to
do you've got this expanded conflict in
Ukraine as I mentioned
Israel and Hamas this war is not abating
and now we've got the US and UK directly
involved plus everyone is aware of the
of the Pacific Theater in Southeast Asia
in which the fears are that China will
make a move on Taiwan so all of this is
laid out before us so when we get
breaking news and videos of these
massive air
strikes it's alarming but I'll tell you
what I think was was alarming first is
when we got these reports several weeks
ago that the rebels were blocking access
to the Red Sea that's shutting down a
massive portion of global trade
including energy trade oil Etc this is
the this is the rep that goes up to the
Sinai Peninsula they're doing it to
Target Israel Egypt's effective the
Mediterranean is affected and now we're
looking at pen for serious War now aside
from that we're going to be talking
about of course we're in Iowa this is
really really awesome the caucuses are
on Monday and a blizzard is about to
slam into us a very serious one I got I
got to tell you Iowa it's beautiful all
of the trees are just blanketed in snow
there's there's a foot or two of snow
everywhere it snowed last night during
the show two or three 3 in and now we're
getting These Warnings this Blizzard's
going to shut everything down but I got
to tell I'm excited for it they're
saying it's going to get down to minus
22° and uh we'll be having a good time
but of course we also must bring up John
fedman who I I nobody wants to believe
he alluded to white genocide in South
Africa but he was talking about Israel
defending Israel and he said South
Africa should not talk about genocide
because of what's going he says when you
look at what's going on there now they
should stay out of it it's like wait
wait wait hold on what did he mean what
did he mean now everybody of course
thought he meant a part hiide right no
he
clarified he said he meant Sudan okay
well look Michael M was right about this
guy whatever it is but a lot of people
think that his initial com comments were
actually about the farmers that are
being killed in South Africa so we'll
talk about that before we get started my
friends head over to Twitter go to x.com
and follow based records B te records
they're producing music they're helping
build the parallel economy they've got a
bunch of great artists they got Chad pra
they got highres and uh of course they
got five times August he's been all of
these people have been on the show we're
big fans and they're helping put
together our Iowa show so yesterday was
Town Hall of f Grand Swami sponsored by
based records and of course we also have
uh today's show tomorrow's show as well
as Monday's live show with a live
audience for the caucus shout out to
based records you can check them out at
Bas records.com but again follow them on
X based records B records and of course
head over to
timcast.net M cuz we're going to have
that members only uncensored show coming
up for you tonight and you don't want to
miss it that's going to be about 10 p.m.
eastern time it's going to be a lot of
fun and uh again smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this a whole lot more and
especially the Iowa caucus is Donald
Trump Jr what's happening man doing a
show here in Iowa you know yeah how are
you doing uh doing well although you
know moving to Florida uh I realized
I've gotten much softer uh coming here
and having it be it's like 20 when I got
here it's like that's that's different
when I'm used to like you know it was 68
the other day in Florida I was like I
can't go outside this is it's over so uh
you got to re acclimate right on so uh I
I don't think you need an introduction
honestly I mean your name it's just
probably probably okay good b or and
different the son of the former and next
president well uh God willing God knows
with what we're seeing uh out there
right now we need someone to do
something different we got a lot to talk
about especially immigration so I
definitely want to jump into this
because Elon Musk has been calling out
there's a bunch of stories some dude
went to one of these facilities and
broke in and filmed inside these these
illegal immigrant facilities that are
being funded by the taxpayer so thanks
for coming man it's going to be a lot of
fun we got Luc caski hanging out yeah
I'm in Miami and um this is something
else this is a little bit different here
uh but my name is lowski of the best
political show.com today I'm wearing a
shirt that reads I identify as a
conspiracy theorist my pronouns are I
told you so because I told you so you
could get it on the best political
shirts.com we also released a big mic
202 24 shirt that automatically was
censored as soon as we released it we
just brought it back up get it on the
best political shirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here did you have a
picture of Big Mike or did you say we we
had more than a picture it's not
familyfriendly is it like the concealed
carry open carry
one it's you know it's it's explicit the
2024 is underlined by we'll keep it
family friendly here this is going to be
for 10:00 I guess we could we can bring
that back up later CU yes Big M oh yes
we go who are you what do you do uh I'm
Ian crossin happy to be here and this
weather reminds me of my childhood man
uh growing up in Ohio ooh that's rough
it wasn't quite negative 10 so I'm I
good a taste of that dude Donna if you
want to harden up do Luke's tactical
training he's over in Miami uh I I do a
lot of shooting so we'll have to make
that happen I do it what I do yeah he
it's running and man I I immediately my
core I realized how how fast your core
gives out if you're not prepped to run
and run and run I'm excited for the
weather the say it's going to be -22 on
caucus day you got to experience it once
if you haven't I was we were up in
Alaska uh over the holidays Alon and I
and it was minus 28 and it's really it
was fun it was very fun yeah it's like a
you know the cold plunge Trend but you
don't have to actually get wet do you do
that just but your face I actually do
like you know and I I try to try my best
to avoid some of the stuff that's
gimmicky but it actually I think it's
great what's your it's amazing for your
dopamine it's amazing to start your day
it's amazing for your overall health and
wellbeing but but when you choose to we
don't choose to do it outside here it's
not fun no no no that's yeah that's a
little different no like I when I go
work out whatever I'll go afterwards
I'll do like you know something hot for
15 20 minutes and then do 5 to seven
minutes and that and you want to do it
in the morning the morning is the best
time to do it you don't want to do it
after you don't want to do it after
exercise because it stops protein
synthesis yeah my problem is it's just
it's literally about time like part of
it it's the relaxation so if I can do it
after my workout it's just hard for me
with my schedule to be like okay I'm
going to go workout then I'm going to go
about my day then I'm going to come back
and get you know sweaty and wet and
dirty again it wake up you're definitely
right let's jump to the news the first
thing I want to show you guys is this
video huge explosion in the capital of
Yemen saana after us air strike This Is
War ladies and gentlemen so uh yeah I
don't I don't think we're get we're
getting any sound out of this but there
is sound yeah sound's not coming through
guys but uh we we'll come back to that
later I'm not super concerned about
people hearing popping noises but this
is the big breaking story we got ABC
News us UK launch large scale
retaliatory strikes against iran-backed
hoodie militants in Yemen the hoodies
had made repeated attacks on the Red Sea
shipping despite us warnings now we have
this story from the conversation why
Yemen's hoodies are getting involved in
the Israel Hamas war and how it could
disrupt global Shipping basically they
there's there's a video I mean have you
guys seen this video where the
helicopter like lands and seizes the
shipping vessel this is nuts we had Eric
Prince on the culture war and he just
outright mentioned I mean this could
shut down a majority of global Shipping
B by controlling this route the end
result is fairly obvious massive
escalation of war in the region Iran of
course has to retaliate in some way so
far they've been having their uh
militias attack us bases but this is a
component of the Israel war in Gaza and
it's I got to tell you it's actually
really sad to see because I remember
when we got the breaking news about the
Abraham Accords during the Trump
Administration and how you get all these
these liberals and and Democrats these
personalities uh claiming that it was
nothing that it was just paying off
people whatever it's not real peace and
my attitude was dude you have flights
traveling over Muslim nations to Israel
from Muslim nations to Israel we are
actually moving forward with the basic
components of long business was being
conducted you because they probably
always wanted to uh you know a lot of
reasons why they couldn't but they they
they changed that and now uh watching
the region fall apart so quickly the
capitulation to Iran and the
you it's just insane man like you know
the the adults were supposed to be back
in charge and
I'm we all knew there's so you knew I
mean of of course you knew you knew with
the Afghan withdrawal right you know
they didn't really want to learn how to
win a war but they wanted to learn about
white rage and uh you know the the worst
I think for me for that one I think we
discussed it last time I was on the show
was just watching you know the the
Secretary of State get up there you know
before Congress uh and do his thing uh
that he would and I quote shocked and
dismayed that the Taliban did not
install a more diverse and inclusive
government but no I mean I was like I
literally like I was like you're joking
right like but but they weren't like
that was like you know the Taliban that
you've been fighting in a war for 20
years that throw homosexuals off
buildings like you thought they were
going to have like you know a trans
Coalition in Islam you like come on well
to be Fair perhaps he thought when China
moved in and took over the region that
maybe a path they move but no that's
actually unfair because China has
masculinity training for their for their
young people and they put out
commercials or or propaganda to get
their young men ripped and Ready for War
they're women too I watched a video of
kids this is how they're training the
kids in schools is they'll each have two
basketballs that their bouncing and then
they jump to the right and they have the
next basketball so there's all these 24
basketballs in a circle and like 12 kids
or there's a lot more than that actually
hey but our kids know that there's
4,762 genders so like we got that going
for us and and that do doesn't even
include the the chinesee super soldier
program um that they also enacted and
are actively genetically gene splicing
individuals in order to become the next
Super Soldier so there's that but this
situation happening in Yemen is is a
pretty big deal it's the United States
it's the United Kingdom they just bombed
the capital of Yemen with support of
Qatar and Saudi Arabia there's a lot of
history here because this is the
continuation of a previous campaign
where the United States and the Saudi
Arabians were essentially working with
al- Qaeda and a lot of Sunni Rebels
trying to get after specifically these
houti Rebels that are tied into Iran so
there's a lot of history here there's a
lot of declarations here there's a lot
of trade on the line there's a lot of
things at stake here that that really
are important to bring up during this
matter as of course this conflict could
expand very easily to Iran and if that
happens it's just going to be
devastating I need to bring up a quick
Point um I think it was like two years
ago Luke made a comment on this show
that Bill Gates was developing
microchips that could uh uh give be
birth function as birth control and I
just started laughing I was like Luke
get out it is not true and then I
Googled it and yeah it's actually yeah
it's an implantable microchip that can
be activated by an app that would turn
on and turn off birth control so for
everybody who heard Luke just say that
China is creating genetically engineered
super soldiers with genan splicing
technology splicing technology I know
there are people watching being like
okay this guy's crazy from the guardian
three years ago China conducting
biological tests to create super
soldiers us spy Chief says intelligence
director John Ratcliff claims human
testing aims to develop Soldiers with
biologically enhanced capabilities okay
fair point maybe the guy was lying but
is it even surprising I mean you just
you understand what like they they're
actually playing to win like is anyone
actually surprised that they would be
doing that like I'm not even a little
bit I'm actually surprised this stories
from three years ago not from 23 years
ago but this is what we know about
imagine the stuff that we don't know
about and to have another Chinese
connection here it was the Chinese that
brokered a larger peace deal that first
ended the war in Yemen just a few months
ago they they brought s Arabia and Iran
to the table and and said hey we're
going to stop fighting each other in in
Yemen because this was a larger proxy
war I I think right now the United
States is restarting this war with Saudi
Arabia not just because of the conflict
not just because of the interest of
Israel but specifically for us petrol
dollar hegemony for Global hemony and to
counter the Chinese here in this very
specific region and and this is
troubling because the Chinese are using
trade as an initiative they're saying
hey Saudi Arabia Iran let's come to the
table let's let's let's get some energy
out there into the world stage the
United States is coming to this
situation saying hey uh we're just going
to bomb stuff here and we're bombing one
of the poorest countries in the world
when I think we could be utilizing a
more diplomatic a more kind of
advantageous policy that would be better
for America's interest and America's
people because right now with the open
borders the yemeni terrorists and and
the rebels how many Iranian sleeper
cells are all over the country right now
they just waiting to be activated it's
not even it's not even Iranian it's it's
it's Isis that the United States
previously supported it's al- Qaeda that
the United States also previously
supported it's it's a lot of
fundamentalists it's a lot of radicals
that could just very easily walk into
the United States and wreck havoc on our
way of life very easily with these
stupid policies we have this tweet from
Mario knul statement from democratic
House member Valerie Howell saying these
air strikes on Yemen were not authorized
by Congress the Constitution is clear
that Congress is the only Authority that
allows military intervention in foreign
conflicts every president must first
come to Congress and requ reest military
authorization regardless of which party
he belongs to I'm really surprised the
Democrat came out and criticized
unilateral military I sort of feel like
they've been really fine with war in
Eastern Europe and sending you know
billions of dollars and then you have
beyond the proxy war whatever happened
to that Tiera guy that was leaking that
we actually had boots on the ground over
there now he's disappeared for six
months we haven't heard anything about
that one uh so well maybe she's upset
because it's not going the missiles
aren't being uh sent to Ukraine perhaps
I mean I'm surprised we actually have
missiles left given the way they've
depleted our stock piles also a real
problem uh especially given what you
brought up as it relates to China being
adversarial and really sort of
encroaching on Taiwan and flying the
sorties over the top of there and you
know our allies are watching what's
going on around the world and we're sort
of an embarrassment I I wonder you know
it's I'm not I'm I'm 37 in two months
I'll be 38 I wonder were we just th
those around uh this age uh you know
like Luke and I are similar age were we
Lucky in growing up in a time where you
had these lesser conflicts that that
appeared you know all around of course
you had Iraq and Afghanistan but you did
not
have basically every region on the verge
of imploding the way but but my point I
guess is before I was born of course
there was Vietnam there was the risk of
nuclear war with the Soviets so maybe
it's just a wakeup call for Millennials
yeah if you watch the borders change
over the last 2,000 years in Europe it's
constant constant Warfare taking over
countries and then World War II happened
Hitler and then all of a sudden it
stopped and it there was no more border
changes because of liberal economic
order we set up this global Military
Police then you see Bosnia break off of
Serbia and that was like the one thing
then the Soviet Union cracked apart and
it really diffused the tensions it so
you I was talking to Scott Harton about
this and you could argue that we're
actually in a state of deescalation but
just like but I don't know there's these
internal conflicts now and and the
things that you don't see on paper if it
feels I got to tell you when I look at
what's going on with the war and the
conf conflict and all this stuff as well
as what's going on with immigration
economics it feels intentional like it's
almost like Joe Biden the Democrats know
they're on the way out and if they can't
have it no one can and so they're just I
mean you look at Afghanistan how is that
anything but intentional you did not
have to abandon the barram Air Force
Base in the middle of the night and not
tell the Afghan Security Forces I mean
line those things up let's say you
decided for some reason you had to
abandon bam okay well you tell the
security forces you don't do it in the
middle of the night you do it in
controlled man let's say for some reason
you could tell them you secure the
materials and the weapons and you get
rid of them before abandoning them to
the Taliban all of those things
happening at once now you look at the
southern border with the Biden
Administration facilitating illegal
immigration it feels like he's this
Angry Kid the Democrats are playing ball
and they're like if I can't play with
the ball and they're going to they're
going to Chuck it over the fence so that
no one else can this well it feels like
a child right because I literally I
remember when that was going on I picked
up my son Spencer he was like I think
nine at the time and I picked up up from
school as as the Afghan withdrawal was
going on and he's literally 9 years old
he's hey Dad uh why why would we take
out the Army before like the people that
helped us you know I'm not going to be
that guy like you know my son was
questioning he's three and he was asking
about nuclear proliferation of the
Korean Peninsula you know the woke
that you see you know out there
you know with you know people sort of
virtue signaling but he was nine and he
was like why why would we leave 86
billion in equipment dad that's that's a
lot of equipment dad like like a
9-year-old knew this you know and yet
you know the the adults back in charge
so it has to be intentional you known
border you could have just maintained
Trump's policies but you know that way
you can't you know the great replacement
Theory it's not a theory I mean it's
reality of course they're doing this at
this point right now I think it's also
fair to understand that maybe what could
have been happening with uh Afghanistan
is a situation where you leave a lot of
arms and weapons to have the Taliban
counter Iran and Iraq in the region as
well as of course there was also a lot
of massive of terrorist attacks that
were just committed inside of Iran by
ISIS Rebels Isis Rebels that also were
armed by US taxpayer dollars and even
had American trucks with American
businesses on the side of them so when
we look at the situation in the Middle
East I think it all boils down to the
military-industrial complex and the
Intel agencies and the powers that be
coming in there and just dropping a
whole bunch of weapons everywhere and
then saying oh there's bad guys picking
up weapons that we dropped that we paid
for that we told them to pick up against
our geopolitical foes that were going
against the US petrol dollar so there's
a lot of history here especially with
the war in Iraq that made Iran as
powerful as they are right now there's a
lot of things that happened specifically
in Syria in Libya that have created the
current talist situation right now and
we need to understand where a lot of
these people are coming from because the
hootsie rebels they are committing
terrorism they are blocking the trade
routes but they're also saying
specifically stop the war in Palestine
and then of course everything will will
calm down here and of course that war is
not going to be stopped the war in palan
I mean I remember when that I first
started seeing that you see the imagery
the pal you know the Hamas soldiers were
carrying m4s they weren't carrying the
traditional AK-47 in in a lot of the
photos that I saw yeah that according to
the Intel reports they got probably from
Ukraine Ukraine or Afghanistan where we
left what was it 47,000 or significantly
more uh so I mean I guess you know
instability in the region works out
great for the Deep State and for the
warmongers but no one else take a look
at this article from Reuters Iran seizes
oil tanker involved in US Iran dispute
and Gulf of Oman State media and it's
retaliation okay
so Iran seizing an oil tanker let me
this is this is direct Iran is no longer
just using proxies to do this it is it
is escalated now to you know nation
state level but the United States
similar action yeah this is a tanker
called the Suz Rajan it's it's changed
names because it used to be a Greek oil
tanker they were delivering selling oil
to the or receiving oil from the
Iranians with and then the US went and
took the tanker from the Greeks and
they're like it's ours now and they sold
all the oil the American Americans sold
their oil for themselves and then now
this is they're taking the the same tank
or they're taking it back um and because
the the the Cassis belly that the United
States had to seize that thing in the
first place was you're using American
Financial systems to transact so you're
violating sanctions on Iran it's now
we're taking it I remember when the
world had a big problem my father's like
hey if we're going to fix these
countries why don't we at least take
some of the oil for ourselves and pay
ourselves back and that was a big
problem for for everyone but apparently
yeah well that's the statement he said
specifically with with Syria and and
essentially that's what the United
States did but there was also a a very
interesting news report I don't know if
you could confirm this or give us more
details about this specifically with
Trump requesting a lot of military
personnel to be removed from Syria and
then the generals kind of lied to him
about it um so so how how can we move
forward with a future Trump presidency
how is this going to be kind of handled
and approached from here when when
clearly there's there's a whole other
power structure here that's creating a
lot of the chaos well listen I think you
have to clean house uh at these places
right you saw it this week alone with
Lloyd Austin I mean he's the Secretary
of Defense he's out it's terrible that
he has cancer but you know we're as you
mentioned we're on the brink of three
now four perhaps different possible
fronts for you know escalated conflict
and he's out of pocket for 5 days you
know they they replaced him with a
lovely lady I'm sure who was on and she
was on vacation in Puerto Rico you know
that's wonderful but like you're the
acting Secretary of Defense while the
secretary of defense is in a hospital
the Biden Administration doesn't know
they didn't bother to tell him till this
week and like all is well folks like I
mean but it but there is a component of
it that's like just showing you that
this deep State this military-industrial
complex they don't believe that they
answer to the civilian you know chain of
command uh they're above and beyond they
know better they haven't really done a
great job of winning wars in the last
you know 50 years or so but like but
they still know better and they're going
to do whatever they want let's jump to
this story we have a tweet from Elon
Musk he says why are they hiding these
centers and of course I highlight Elon
Musk because when someone with 100 1 70
or so million people posts a video
people take notice and the Tweet here is
actually uh it's from info uncensored I
believe that's what's watermarked in the
video this video is going so viral I
don't know where the original Source but
this is a man who goes into one of these
migrant facilities the Randall Island
illegal immigrant Center and he gets a
view into all of the tents I mean this
is a massive facility we heard that I
believe it's in Chicago the taxpayer is
spending $7,000 per illegal IM imigrant
per uh what is it per month and they're
bringing in thousands and they're
building these facilities you take a
look at some of this stuff it is
absolutely shocking here we go Henry
84,000 a year just so we understand
that's above median income in this
country fairly significantly actually uh
I want I want everyone to understand
what this means because the Biden
Administration is facilitating this
directly this means that when you go to
work and you make $50,000 a year and
you're wondering why your gas is
expensive why your food is more
expensive and why you can't afford to
pay the rent
just just remember that the illegal
immigrant in Chicago is getting $84,000
a year in benefits that you are
contributing to through your tax
dollars that's crazy that's a lot of
money you get to pay for yourself your
kids their schooling their health care
as well as a few million uh illegal
immigrants who you know seemingly
because I know the rocket scientists and
the nuclear physicists they can't get
into the country but if you bring no
skills and you're going to be a
dependent uh which means you're going to
be on the Democrat Party adult and vote
accordingly uh you can come in uh with
Reckless abandon it's also incentivizing
a lot of people to come in that of
course will be taking instead of giving
because if you created a situation
saying hey you guys could make something
out of yourself but you have to work for
it there's going to be opportunities
where you could prove yourself that
that's something else completely
different compared to we're going to
give you a bunch of free stuff
California you get a free sex change
California you get free healthcare and
then on top of this money that is given
to um these specific migrants we have to
understand there there's also a larger
economic cost to housing the price of
housing is going to be going up as
there's going to be less available of it
the price of Labor is going to be going
down specifically with a lot of labor
now being available for a lot of workers
and it's going to get worse yeah well
the hedge funds are buying all the
housing they want you to be permanent
renters you know it's uh I I said it
earlier in a speech today here in Iowa
just if you had this sort of proverbial
Manchurian Candidate and you were trying
to destroy America from within what
would you do differently than today's
Democrat Party and the answer I can't I
liter cannot think of anything that they
could get away with beyond what they're
actually getting away with that could
make it worse it's it's hard to believe
it's almost like if you were trying to
implement this plan to destroy the
country they got a pretty good one oh
it's a it's a phenomenal plan must cost
a lot of money it's doing great our
enemies are laughing their asses off you
know China's uh just loving what's going
on right now they couldn't have
orchestrated it better themselves let me
pull up this article because it's going
to get worse New York Post Elon Musk
warns migrants are quote coming for your
homes after New York City kids forced
out of the classroom now the corporate
press doing what they do best I loved
how they did this to your dad Don Elon
Musk reports he comments on what's
already been reported they call him a
liar I saw this happen with uh during
the Trump Administration so many times
to your dad he comes out and he goes oh
now they're saying they're going to do X
Y and Z media then reports Donald Trump
lies about X Y and Z and it's like no no
no no no no I reported on exactly what
Don said what Trump said two weeks ago
Elon Musk there was a report in
Massachusetts I believe it was and in
New York that they were suggesting that
private residents give up space in their
homes to illegal immigrants the
lieutenant governor of Massachusetts and
that's the New York Post owned by Fox
News That's conservative programming you
know let's you know air quote it but
conservative programming actually taking
that approach that tells you everything
you need to know about our corporate
media even on the conservative side they
they want to put Elon Musk warns in the
headline they could have said Elon Musk
highlights comments from lieutenant
governor they could have pointed out but
I'm not going to I'm not going to roast
the New York Post for simply saying Elon
said it fine he did but the issue is
that now you got the corporate press
claiming that Elon Musk is lying or or
exaggerating in these claims when all
Elon did was read the New York Times and
then tweet here's my here's a here's a
thing I read well they did the same
thing to him about the Dei in like the
airplane thing it's like oh he's he's
racist he's like no I just want good
Pilots like you're doing programs that
are choosing people that are not the
best pilots and it's not an unreasonable
ass to say I would just like a competent
pilot I don't care if they're green blue
purple it makes no difference to me I
just like them to be able to fly a plane
but that's not what they're trying to
push he retweeted James Lindsay who was
highlighting the diversity initiatives
and the bonus structure it's not just
like we want to try and hire more people
it was like you'll get paid more if you
hire non-whites and so Elon said they're
they're sacrificing would you he said
would you want to fly in an airline that
is sacrificing uh uh the skill or
sacrificing safety for diversity and
then the media attacked him claiming I
love this NBC said Elon must claim this
without evidence and I'm like what do
you mean it's their policy he literally
retweeted James Lindsay's it's it's a
document from the airline breaking down
their diversity initiative yeah it's
a I feel like I wake up a lot of times
like right now and I'm just waiting for
like Ashton Kutcher to like jump out of
a cake and be like all we're you're just
being punked like no I feel like I'm the
star of The Truman Show at times like
there's no way this is real right
there's TV cameras following me around
in every room that I'm in because they
must be because no rational person uh
could do these things and yet and yet
it's happening I feel like that too and
it's like I think it's our bias is Free
Speech bias we've got this bias that the
American Constitution is preeminent and
will always stand but I think the most
of the world just wants it gone they
want us to live like like digital surfs
and not I don't know most of the world I
think it's the but but the people who
are in charge because the people that
actually hold that power you know the
world economic Forum guys like they're
never going to you know you can't drive
your car but I'll take my G6 you know
which will burn more fuel in 30 minutes
of air travel than you will in your
entire lifetime but no it's different
for me because I'm doing good and I'm
smarter than you and I know more so you
eat bugs I'll eat steak you you rent
your home from me forever and the second
we control the entire rental market will
jack up the rent and you'll be surfed
for Life yeah that's exactly true it's
not most of the world most of the world
wants free speech and they would they
would rise up against their tyrannical
governments if they thought that they
could win but it's these power
structures that are like trying to stomp
out speech it's really insane look I I I
I said something rather uh intense I'll
call it last week when I when I'm
watching these videos of Law Enforcement
Officers facilitating crimes against our
country on the southern border
particularly let's go back in time a
month or so I we heard Texas said we're
going to make it illegal to to cross our
borders without you know through through
the proper process the Biden
Administration threatened them I
entertain the the the the the issue what
happens when Texas state law enforcement
confronts federal law enforcement and
federal law law enforcement is
explicitly breaking the law first let's
start with a simple question if a police
officer one day decides to rob a bank do
we have someone go and arrest that
police officer and of course there's no
question robbing a bank what if he was
told to rob the bank by the chief of
police yeah yeah it still doesn't matter
he still went and did it what we have
now is the Biden Administration
instructing law enforcement we saw the
videos of the bulldozers lifting up the
razor wire they are facilitating illegal
activities against this country
violations of the Constitution shout out
toosie who's sitting in sitting over
here article 4 section 4 they're
supposed to protect us from Invasion
instead they're facilitating it now
we're entering this this this now the
Biden Administration is suing Texas over
this to try and continue the
facilitation of illegal immigration what
happens when a Texas law enforcement
officer says you sir I don't know who
you are I don't care who you are you are
breaking the law and you are under
arrest and that guy says I'm a federal
agent don't you don't you try it well
listen it's it's getting to be
interesting and i' I've sort of gone to
Great Lengths only because I see so many
of these guys you know FBI agents or
retired guy they come up to me and they
see what's going on whether it was to
our family or whether it's just in
general and they're like you know it's a
tarnish on our badge it's you know they
saw the maral Lago FBI raid and they're
like this is insane this is ridiculous
I'm like so I've always made sort of the
distinction between the bureaucrat at
the top that's just you know beholden to
the politics and frankly all leftists at
this point and the door kickers but
we're getting to the point where it's
like hey guys if you're just like well
I'm just doing my job I'm just doing my
job I'm just doing my job literally
every day someone's rights being
violated the Constitution being violated
the law being viol like when like when
do we stop saying like hey man like
maybe you don't get a pass forever of
just doing your job maybe more people
need to speak out you saw what happened
with the FBI whistleblowers calling out
you know the entrapment or the Gretchen
Whitmer uh you know fake you know
kidnapping and you know I'm sure all the
stuff around January 6th you know the
insanity there oh we can't show the
video because there's too many of our
agents in the crowd it's like so they
were there but they didn't do anything
to stop it it's almost like they wanted
it to happen when do we say like hey you
no longer get the free pass right uh I
was just doing my job because eventually
it doesn't fly this and this is what I
said last week that the there there are
people driving buses okay there there's
a report that I've highlighted several
times from several years ago of two uh
military uh uh uh I I I don't they're
enlisted I guess criminally charged for
trafficking illegal aliens the federal
it was a US attorney in Texas saying
these these guys were transporting
migrants for cash okay now you've got
these James O'Keefe did this video he
filmed this Bus full of illegal
immigrants and they're being trafficked
you've got these big Airlines
trafficking illegal immigrants I want to
see those people driving those buses in
handcuffs yeah I want to see a parw walk
I want to we we cannot have a country
where someone driving this bus
trafficking engaging in human
trafficking says my boss told me to do
it it'll be fine in this video with
James they swerve in and out of traffic
trying to get away from him they go into
off ramps and then back on the highway
and then they call the police to try and
get rid of them when they're in fact the
ones breaking the law so what I said and
I'll say it again is that I hope your
dad gets elected I hope Donald Trump
wins in 2024 and I hope we don't got to
be crazy and arrest literally every
single person but if you are on camera
if there is evidence of you facilitating
crimes against this country and working
with coyotes for human trafficking
purposes I hope you are criminally
charged and arrested and I will do
everything with my within my power as
some dude to complains on the internet
to say this to anyone of influence I
I'll get i'll get me too I'll say I'll
be right there with you and when they
come to take us to the Googs it won't be
under our Administration but the second
the Democrats take over because they've
sh they're willing to do that uh it'll
no but you're right we we we see it
happening every day it's it's across the
board you know they're throwing out
veterans from uh public housing to put
illegals there they're taking over
hotels paying the owners of the hotels
money but this is tax it's not like New
York's functioning well right it's been
it's sort of a disaster and now we're
going to spend hundreds of millions of
dollars doing it you saw the do you see
that article I think it was NBC or CBS
News Texas spent a100 million shipping
illegals out of the state what a bad use
of funds they go well if they sent
100,000 immigrants out of the state of
Texas bust them all over the country got
them out of Texas that's about a bucks a
person how much would it have cost Texas
to keep them there so I mean the the
article is so gaslighting it's like oh
my God they spent $100 million I'm like
that that would have that could have
been billion in the next two years just
keeping them there you know but they
expect you to not believe you know
beyond the by line or not to see through
it where they've been so it's so
flagrant these days but I'm not going to
I'm not going to defend Texas Florida or
some of these other states I know we all
laughed when they shipped illegal
immigrants like Martha's vineard
but when they take illegal immigrants
from the border the Biden Administration
facilitates this and lets them in and
then Texas pays these companies to ship
around the country that is part of the
human trafficking process technically
smuggling it's uh tra it could some of
this might be trafficking trafficking is
when the person doesn't want to be
shipped uh but if it's of their own
valtion and they want to be part of it
then they're being smuggled human
smuggling yep so I I think there needs
to be I I I do not accept that this is
some kind of broad brilliant play for
Texas to be like aha we'll take those
illegal immigrants and send them to
other parts of the country the problem
while I I get what you're saying at the
same time I think you know you see the
people in Chicago being like wait a
minute This is BS like this can't be
happening it's like well no no no you
guys have been yelling about being a
sanctuary City and everyone's supposed
to be this but now that you actually
deal with it and when you look at the
problem in New York or Chicago just
based on numbers it's a tiny fraction of
what Texas Arizona you know border
states actually have to deal with and
all of a sudden now they're waking up so
you know you you do need sort of the
shot across the bows like hey if you
want to be a sanctuary City we've been
very clear in Texas that they're not
going to be they don't want to be uh and
they've been dealing with these problems
for many decades frankly it's much worse
now but you know it's really easy to be
behind your high fence in Hollywood and
talk about how wonderful it is those
people aren't taking anyone else in and
when they show up in their backyard all
of a sudden it's a problem which which
is I which is why I can respect it to a
certain degree I still think it's bad
however that being said that's why I'm
saying the Biden Administration is
facilitating this
and when Texas tries to do something
about it the bid Administration goes
after them the only real course of
action they have seems to be this
political play of send them to the
sanctuary cities and force these people
to recognize what they have supported by
voting for Joe Biden and these Democrats
and in fact because of this it is a
large contributing factor to why I I got
to tell you it's wild to see these
videos out of Chicago where you have
people in the black community saying
they're voting for Donald Trump I've met
some of them and you have the youth vote
in there were three polls I believe so
far showing 18 to 34 year olds leaning
Republican for Donald Trump and that to
me is shocking it is but I think when
people realize hey you're a young person
you can't afford rent you can't afford
work you're living paycheck to paycheck
your Future's been stolen from you all
of these great crises the co lockdowns
all of these things you've seen and then
they tell you $84,000 a year going to
the pocket of that guy and it's coming
from your paycheck they're going to say
I'm going to vote for the other guy yeah
I mean we had it pretty good under those
time you know again I I see it and you
know I don't pretend to be I'm the son
of a billionaire from New York and I you
know I took my kids I had him I took him
to Alaska I just remember this one cuz
it stuck out particular I took him to
Alaska we were just doing a father son
like fishing trip and we came back and
we're like the Anchorage Airport and I
got McDonald's for myself uh a
14-year-old and an 11year old and it was
like 39 bucks and I was like oh my god
dude if I'm feeling sticker shock uh you
know what's happening to the rest of the
country you know I had a you know a
mortgage uh readjust cuz I had to
maintain something for my ex-wife or
whatever you know a mortgage readjust
that I wasn't paying attention for and
just the interest alone just from the
change in interest rate from you know a
5-year arm readjusting was like oh my
God you know if you took it
proportionally to like the average cost
of a home in America it it could be
debilitating you know relative to Med
median income like I want to I want to
ask you a question yeah before I read
the next article I want to ask you uh
Donald Trump gets uh reelected elected
again in the end of this year what's the
first thing he does what's the first
thing he will do to alleviate the
problem of this massive illegal
immigration flooding this country you
you shut down the border to stop the
continued spread you get rid of the
incentives to you know listen they
they're literally incentivized to and
and by the way it's a human crisis that
most people can't even imagine I mean I
I'm a big Outdoorsman Hunter and stuff
like that I have friends all over South
Texas with ranches and stuff I mean
they're literally finding dead bodies
all over the place uh from I mean you
know that that desert is not an easy
want to cross and the coyotes aren't
exactly friendly people and they don't
exactly do the right thing I mean it it
is a crisis on a humanitarian scale that
most people you'll never hear the
numbers you'll never hear about it and
imagine what what's reported in America
is going to be very different than what
doesn't make it in the Thousand Miles it
takes to cross Mexico so you you shut
that down you get rid of the incentives
you do the things like remain in Mexico
you hold them accountable for some of
these things and then you do have to
start the deportation effort because
these millions like you got to do it and
the way to eat an elephant is one bite
at a time man you got to you got to
start you got to you got to go
aggressive and this is what they're
priming us for with this article from
cnr.com the reason why I asked whoopy
Goldberg claims Trump will put people in
camps they're in camps right now we see
the videos right it's Cages under Trump
when it's Obama it's a lovely facility
that happens to be a cage but we won't
call it that exactly and so this is what
they're priming us for we need Mass
deportation yeah we have 10,000 plus
people per day illegally entering the
country AOC says just give them papers
that's not going to that's not going to
solve the problems of the economic
crisis there's more illegals coming into
the country on an annual basis than
there are American children being born
here right what they're what they're
prepping us for with these statements
from whoopy Goldberg is that when Donald
Trump does begin the process of I would
just say uh um typical deportation
processes they are going to produce
videos and photos and they're going to
claim he's Hitler and it's happening and
they're going to use this as propaganda
to incite violence yeah AOC crying at
the border wall of course but because
they've done that the projection is
already happening uh you know everyone's
a fasc except for when they're
functioning like fascists and you've
seen there's no limit to what the
Democrat Party will do to retain power
we've been watching that for the last
few years I mean uh it's scary stuff but
yes they are definitely doing I'm
surprised anyone can actually listen to
the view at this point with a straight
face um who are the people who still do
I honestly I don't know it sort of
interesting I I did when my first book
uh triggered came out uh they had me on
The View and it was the I think it was
like the 5,000th episode of The View and
you know so you know they're going a
little bit I actually got after a while
I actually you know you fight back and
whatever I actually turn the audience
and whoopy was there mfing uh the
audience in in the commercial break it
was sort of amazing I wish we could get
the footage of that they'll never allow
that to get out there but it was sort of
like they're used to people going on
these shows and they're so desperate to
get a little bit of air time because
they're selling their book or whatever
their you know product they got
or whatever it may
I was there for a book thing they didn't
even ask me about my book I figured if
they're going to have me on there uh at
least you have the courtesy of that but
it was just an attack session so then
when I sort of went after whoopy for the
you know sort of uh allowing you know
pedophile Roman palansky and justifying
that and joy bear for blackface and it
was I just sort of have fun because I
just like you what if this goes really
wrong I just Google like what are the
dumbest things ever said on The View and
it's like there was a long list but
there was some pretty obvious ones and
you know they lost their whole audience
but they still have this sort of they
must have some sort of capture probably
you know white Suburban uh virtue
signaling Housewives uh that they're
able to manipulate with their nonsense
cuz you know they're correcting
themselves all the time but you know it
doesn't matter they they get the hit out
there the media picks it up it's pushed
very effectively through social media as
though it's the gospel as opposed to
nonsense uh so yeah there's no question
that's what they're doing wasn't it uh
Kelly Osborne that came out and said on
The View specifically that we need all
these immigrants here because they're
going to be cleaning our toilet yeah and
and I quote Donald Trump who's going to
scrub your toilet if they're and
everyone like who she's like no no this
is what I mean but that that's the
problem they don't they don't get it
yeah do you guys think that there's
value to building a wall now
again a big graphine wall Jo Biden is
selling the wall off did you know that
we need a nice strong we paid for it we
then sell off the components rather than
taking you know literally you they could
have just completed it uh in the areas
that it matter I mean it was clearly
effective you saw the numbers but they
didn't want to complete it so instead
they paid for the material now they're
selling off the remaining material so
that you have to buy it again if and
when someone else ever becomes takes
office like there's literally no it's
like Wuhan lab League Theory like of
course it came from the lab like of
course this is intentional from them of
course they want unfettered access to
people who are going to be dependent and
who will ultimately vote Democrat like
they they offer nothing else if you're
not a dependent at this point I get
nervous about the deportation stuff cuz
I like logically it makes sense but
realistically I see the horror of like
people with their cell phones recording
their mother screaming as she's being
pulled out of her living room and then
like every day that kind of stuff on
social media getting played on NBC and
like now imagine this now imagine a
video of a woman crying and screaming as
she's being pulled from a bank vault
carrying a bunch of cash yeah we we we
don't we don't look at that crime being
committed and go oh that poor woman or
the seventh time deported guy that raped
women with Reckless abandon or or you
drove drunk for the fifth time in the
United States and killed someone's son
or smuggling fentel across the border
time and time again killing hundreds of
thousands of americ
there's a video of a man being arrested
in the subway and the cops are roughing
him up you know not not really hitting
or anything but they're like grabbing
his arm they're pulling it he's
resisting and there's all these comments
on Twitter they're like why is he doing
why are the cops doing this to this man
he didn't even do anything he was
fighting cops he he he jumped the turn
they said stop we're going to give you a
ticket he fought with the cops they
fought back and arrested him yes that's
how you enforce laws that's victim crime
this this is victimless crime which is
part of what makes deportation
challenging like these Tech
they're technically attacking everyone
by displacing us but real you have
verify you make it you create incentives
where it's harder for them to do maybe
they honestly you probably have a lot of
people self-de deporting because if
they're not able to take advantage of
the systems if we're not just abjectly
writing them checks and giving them
phones and telling them hey here's a
phone here's a couple thousand bucks a
month and you know why don't you see us
in 2037 for your court date you know
there are things you can do uh that
don't make it so simple where the
American taxpayer isn't footing the bill
uh in
perpetuity you've got these people
hiring human traffickers actual human
traffickers or Smugglers I'm not no not
Smugglers traffickers there are
traffickers who kidnap kids who rape
them drag them across the border and
these are the same people that the other
illegal imans will go to and pay yeah
and so we hear these these horrifying
stories that these Smugglers let's say
the lighter version of the coyotes they
overwhelmingly rape young girls as they
do this it's not a victimless crime this
should not be allowed to continue now
like 40 40% it's an insane it's not like
oh there's you occasionally it happens
and they and I know they went after my
father a lot when he said it but that's
the reality I had Tom Holan the former
head of ice on my my triggered podcast
like two weeks ago and he's talking
about I mean the the stories that these
guys could tell if you could show those
videos if you could show those stories
to the American public uh you'd be
building a wall in about 3 seconds if
people understood the reality of what's
actually going on down there I've done
some reporting on the ground of the
refugee crisis that was spurred on by a
lot of the Caravans that ended up in
Tijana and there was a lot of problems
not just when it came to sanitation not
just when it came to a lot of the
diseases and viruses that were being
spread everywhere but specifically with
assaults on women and children
specifically to the point where they
needed an entire other area to House
people and to to put people in because
of the huge amounts of violations that
were happening against women and that
were happening against children and when
when you look at a large number of the
people coming through it's fighting age
males uh it's it's males that of course
are in the peak of their age they're
they're coming here to this country and
this is something that that sadly we
don't hear talked about at all because
there's a big censorship effort trying
to deny us this reality but but a lot of
these people are lied to they're told
hey we're going to give you all this
stuff there's all these opportunities
just come on here everything's going to
be amazing and great for you and for a
lot of them it's not and it's not just
hurting Americans but it's also hurting
them as well as of course a lot of
multinational corporations also take
advantage of them they put them in of
course laborous situations where they
don't have to pay them like they would
an American and they're the ones also
being taken advantage of and from a
humanitarian perspective we have to
understand here I I understand what Ian
is trying to convey but but I think just
stopping the the incentivizing of this
larger program from moving forward just
stop funneling it stop giving it money
that would solve a lot of the problems
go after the corporations hiring these
people go after all these incentives and
then you won't need to force Deport
people people won't leave because the
people will naturally will leave Donald
Trump did this yeah like by the way
famously when after several uh meat
processing plants we've talked about it
quite a bit we we we've seen this done
it's not you know that and that's sort
of the thing about my father running
right now right like he did all of the
things he said he was like we we know we
can do this you know them pretending
like oh it's impossible we just can't do
it like what are you talking like we had
these numbers down I mean you know the
amount of you know you talk about the
fightinge males but they they showing up
with young girls that clearly aren't
their children and they they won't do
the DNA test anymore because it doesn't
matter and they're just like well we
just got to push it through it's too
much to handle I mean we are enabling a
humanitarian crisis of epic proportions
and like you know those those same
Hollywood Elites are just fine with that
maybe listen I guess they're all on the
epan type so they're probably you
know let the attention go elsewhere you
have a 27-year-old male with a
10-year-old girl crossed the border and
the Trump Administration said who is
that young girl because we know the kis
are are trafficking and raping young
girls and then the Democrats go oh no
they're separating the daughter from her
father it's like that's some guy with
some kid who is trafficking them and we
know that there's a large amount of rape
going on we need to figure out if these
are victims being trafficked but these
these these liberals these Democrats the
corpor r they don't care would you guys
support military intervention in Mexico
what does that mean uh dropping bombs uh
targeted assassinations like total just
going yes cartels like I mean in
proportional conflict is the cartel not
an enemy combatant of the United States
are they not a clear and present danger
no but we we even have to clarify that I
I I I think military just military
conflict in any country can be justified
it just depends on the context if like
Mexico started ritualistically just
executing anybody who was near the
border even American
citizens yes absolutely if cartels were
kidnapping American citizens and then
killing them Mark in reprisal in fact
The Mexican government should be working
with us to stop that that that stuff and
if they don't then we go after them for
the time being I don't know if I I know
enough about the current conflict with
cartels that justifies bombings and
assassinations there's also a lot of
links to the CIA and Intel agencies that
helped a lot of cartels out and work
with the cartels and and are
participating in larger drug trades that
of course are are bringing over the
fentanyl here into the United States as
well as of course they have a history of
bringing in crack cocaine um and
introducing it to of course the local
populations here here as well so I don't
think that's going to happen Ian mainly
because of there's a conflict of
interest yeah it's on the border which
has its own risk you don't want I mean I
don't know I don't think anyone in
America wants to be fighting on the
border right now and that would could
open that up um so you think that
they're prioritizing economic like
economics over human life the CIA and
whoever's yeah I don't think it's
economics for the American public though
I think it's economics for their own War
chest and coffers I mean that that's
probably uh historically far more
accurate than anything that would be
positive for American economics
but man it's it's hard like I I got a
call from a buddy uh this week had some
friends in they were in a hunting camp
in Sonora in Mexico across the border
and cartel's grabbed a couple guys shot
a bunch of the guys they were with and I
guess you know they left some of the
Americans but like I mean they are
active doing this by the way and they're
also taking over all of the law
enforcement they're more heavily armed
and weaponized than a lot of the Mexican
military I mean this is uh this is a war
zone I I think you know as as Luke is
pointing out with the Intel agencies I
think there's more to it than we realize
100% that these cartels are working with
some level of you know the US government
yeah but I think that's far more of a
threat to the United States than
anything going on in the Ukraine right
now uh I I think it's far more relevant
to our well-being uh than anything going
on there but you know we're fine sending
150 billion to them without
accountability or well there's a lot of
documented cases especially with
operation Fast and Furious especially
with the Obama Administration especially
with even US Special Forces creating
essentially one of the fiercest cartels
in all of Mexico as well so the history
is there and this is the public stuff
that we know about what don't we know
about as of course almost every step of
the way here we see direct government
intervention you could go all the way
back to Iran Contra that was another
major Scandal that the Intel agencies
were a part of that they were never held
responsible for the guy in charge of it
got a spot on Fox news for for some
freaking reason and uh when you when we
don't have accountability for these
Intel agencies they're going to continue
to do what they did before so is there a
way to get any kind of accountability
here from them that that's a question
that I think a lot of people have on
their minds especially with how
egregiously they've been overacting
against uh you know your dad listen I I
think you got to try and I think that I
I think now that you know I mean you had
there was some nice things about coming
in as an outsider but I think there were
also some disadvantages right you didn't
who do you actually trust you know The
Plum Book which is you know the
president sort of 4,000 employees you
know they they put into those positions
like I don't know 4,000 people you know
you're going to find 4,000 people that
are actually going to believe in your
movement and this or you know they show
you know they showed you three Tweets in
the two weeks in the hiring process and
oh yeah no we're pretty for it now he
understands who the snakes are who the
bad people are I think that's what
scares him more I think that's why you
have sort of uh the retaliation going so
much more aggressively at him because he
is the only threat to their hegemony
there um you know you've SE Nikki Haley
it's like you know she was created in a
laboratory uh you know by the neocons
it's like the perfect uh you know never
ending War uh Republican it's like Liz
Cheney um what do you guys think about
VI honestly I I like a lot of what he's
saying I you know I I I do I've been
saying that fairly publicly for quite
some time uh I say it my podcast a lot
um you know I guess and I'd like to get
to know him I don't actually know him
but I I'd like to get to know him um I I
agree with a lot of what he's saying I
on the corollary to that I have a lot of
people you know when I'm just doing my
live stream whatever well but when I
don't trust him I was like well I
understand that too because you know I
don't know where he was in 16 18 20 you
know 22 uh I believe he's certainly you
know of the other people other than my
father on that stage he's the smartest
of them by far so I also believe he's
smart enough to tell you what you want
to hear if you're the conservative based
voter but you know I I I kind of want to
believe you so maybe the Tak some time I
think he's developing I've always
bitched we have no bench you know after
Donald Trump we don't who's the guy you
know that before the primary I mean like
I was like two or three with the STIs
I'm like but like I was a real estate
guy until I just started yelling because
no one else is fighting so I might as
well do it we we don't have that bench
of guys that are going to be rock stars
I think there's some guys coming along
you know at JD Vance uh there's there's
other guys that are now coming out but
like you know I said it today John
fedman is more based than you know
three4 of the United States Senate like
with what he's saying these days and I'm
like meaning on the Republican side and
how does that happen so we need more of
a base we need more people who are
willing to sort of fight for that
America first movement and you know my
father gets that now but you know I I
want to believe I want to believe that
he can get there I I I don't know enough
yet so Donald Trump said that he already
picked his VP candidate already uh we
also have Tucker Carlson and Elon Musk
saying that they want to see Vivic Remis
Swami as the vice president for Donald
Trump what do you think are the chances
of that possibly happening and who would
you like to see as a VP well I've been
pretty vocal at you know i' I'd love to
see Tucker um I I I think that would by
the way if
only if only to watch the Tucker Carlson
Camala Harris vice presidential debate
like you know I think by the way make no
mistake I think he'd be awesome across
the board uh but like that would sort of
just be you know uh the icing on the
cake I I think he should take VI I think
VI's like a bulletproof vest because if
you let V into the presidency he's going
to upend the power structure and he'll
do it rapidly yeah I think I think
there's a lot of guys like that and you
know I think there's a lot of positions
that you could put disruptors like that
in to go break these things up at the
CIA you don't just have the guy that's
going okay fine I let you know Obama did
the thing he did probably best was get
these people that were in otherwise
appointed positions entrenched in these
sort of unfireable roles you know
they're like tenure at Harvard like well
you got tenures you can't you you can be
totally incompetent they totally
politicize and weaponize these
institutions and so you need someone who
has the the balls frankly to be able to
go in there and break that up and I
think we understand that now and uh
coming in you know with four years of
experience understanding who those guys
are I mean you mentioned John rackliffe
earlier talking about those things I
mean he'd be you know a guy that could
be great at some of these things uh you
know I think that's the most important
thing we can actually do to save the
Republic I I think VI knows that he's
the runnerup and I don't mean that
disrespectfully I think VI's absolutely
fantastic and I think you make a great
point about needing a bench you know VES
he brought this up yesterday we did this
town hall with him and he was basically
saying come next year we should not be
surprised at what they are willing to do
to stop Donald Trump and if they succeed
it would be a mistake if we look back
and said we should have done something
different I think his view is basically
I'm going to put it more bluntly than he
would he is the safety net in the event
that they go they they do the the most
egregious they're already doing it with
the criminal trials the fraud trial but
I think V's view is he genuinely thinks
that they're going to maliciously and
nefariously in some way remove your dad
from this race and so he's going to be
waiting as a safety net in case how far
do you think they could they could go
here they
they I don't think there's any
limitations I mean they they've shown
that right I mean again uh you know the
disparate treatment uh of conservatives
or people who were American First Look
at J Sixers versus you know uh Summer of
Love riers I mean you're seeing people
you know who peacefully you know they're
literally walking through the Velvet
ropes taking selfies it's like well that
person got seven years and you know you
burn down a Target murder a few people
it's like well that's different that's
for social justice it's you know go you
we're going to make you a yeah no it's
mostly peaceful while the building's
burning in the background it's um you
know we we've seen there's no limit to
that the people who have been uh
screaming about you know fascism you
know are trying are are jailing their
political opponents uh they're trying to
take out uh you know the leader of the
opposition party I mean they're actually
being fascists in real life I mean that
that shouldn't be lost on anyone it's
it's fascinating in this uh this this
hearing on presidential immunity the
Democrats and the corporate press latch
on to the argument that if a president
were to order the assassination of his
political rival he could not be
prosecuted unless he was a impeached and
convicted first if as so long as so long
as it as an uh it was an official duty
at the same time they're arguing like
how dare you insinuate and go after your
political rival in such a criminal way
and it's like this trial is literally
that the fact that Donald Trump is on
trial is because a a a the president is
attacking his political rival and making
it's it's the brilliant projection
manifest make your rival defend himself
when you're the one actually attacking
your rival well their their entire thing
is projection but I mean imagine imagine
Donald Trump gets back in do we do we go
back and try Obama for murder because he
droned American citizens in the Middle
East I mean no yes that's the precedent
they're setting so I mean there there
comes a point like hey I I'd love
nothing more to than to not have to have
those conversations right but we are
playing t-ball on our side while the
other side is playing fast pitch hard
ball you can't win or you know get to a
point where you you actually have a
chance unless you start playing the game
that they are they hated Trump because
he was more aggressive he said the quiet
Parts out loud he actually followed
through didn't just sort of tell the
people you know in a nice room in Iowa
what they wanted to hear and then well
we go back to DC it's like I was just
kidding that's different uh that's what
we've seen from you know all of the
other candidates uh you know thus far
and and again maybe if if that gets the
exception to that I feel like he wasn't
he didn't come from that machine there
might be other ways to win in a game
where they're playing fast pitch and you
you've been practicing t-ball is that
like you buy the company that owns the
game or you you find out some outside
interference pattern that can make it
more of a victory for everybody involved
well we're starting to you know what
that outside interference pattern is the
insanity of their actions right like I
I've been sort of interested I'm
watching the bill acman thing sort of
fold you know unfold with Harvard right
but like people like well he finally did
that I go but you know what it wasn't
finally know I was talking with this
Josie earlier I was like no when I first
sort of got on his you know where he
came on my radar Beyond you know sort of
being a New York hedge fund billionaire
maybe there's some similar circles there
but like was during the Kyle Written
House stuff uh and I don't know if you
remember but like one like his first
real sort of long form tweet that became
political was he's like I'm watching the
Kyle writtenhouse trial with my wife
here and I'm hearing the testimony and
I'm seeing the alleged and I was like I
was told that this guy's a white
supremacist who killed a bunch of innoc
African-Americans and the fact set that
was laid out very succinctly and very
stringently by the mainstream media does
not align with anything that I'm
actually seeing in this case and he goes
it reminds me of business where I've
been a you know a big player for you
know 40 years half a century whatever it
is and I'd read you know the Wall Street
Journal and I'm either a player or I
know the players that they're talking
about I know the deals intimately I'm a
subject matter expert and I laugh at how
ridiculous the reping is but then I turn
the page and I read another article
about something that I'm not a subject
matter expert and I just assume it's
correct whereas I should be assuming
it's not he goes all this time it was
crazy and I just remember him then going
he goes I just got a call from the New
York Times asking if my Twitter account
was hacked and he was just literally
objectively stating the facts and so
there are PE and this was a bulvik I
mean you know major billionaire Democrat
donor yada y y like who's like it's just
not lining up and now you see what
happened with Harvard and then they went
after his wife maybe you know ner oxman
could be like the Helen of Troy for like
facts and reality uh if if it's if it's
just exposing this you get 10 other guys
like him finally having the balls to
actually do it because they're going to
try to destroy him and there's a
consequence to that and but you get
enough people you know maybe there is
some chance uh that we wake up to that
so much of what we've been told and so
much of what we've read is just all a
lie designed intend called called the
Gman Amnesia effect where you read the
news and they say you know Donald Trump
does backflip and you're like wow I
didn't realize he could do that then you
turn the page and you're a plumber and
it's like pump you know Plumbing tube
gets put backwards up down and you're
like wait that makes no sense this is
fake news yeah you know Donald Trump
tried stealing the Beast he was able to
subvert too heavily armed young secret
service agent I was like I don't know if
he did that i' like and the best part
was they claimed he went through he he
phase shifted with his superpowers by
vibrating like the flash through the
barricade between the driver and the
like I I've been in the Beast I've been
in it like it ain't happening and like
you know my my father's a you know
vibrant and agile young man but you he's
probably not taking out to Secret
Service guys you know but but that was
the Gospel that happened Cassidy
Hutchinson you know she testified at the
January 6 committee that that was what
happened now the guys that were actually
in the car say no that that didn't
happen that was ridiculous but the
second they knew that was happening they
weren't going to allow that testimony
because the testimony though fact would
refute the The Narrative The Narrative
they weaponized so effectively you know
when it comes out two years later oh it
doesn't matter we got what we wanted we
weaponized it fully let's talk about uh
what was the Harvard thing let's talk
about fman you want to move on to yeah I
want talk about fman har was all the
stuff with you know Claud and gay and
the plagiarism Scandal the plagiarism
Scandal and Dei as well as by the way
just being sort of uh let's just call it
Les a fair on the actions of students
you know perpetuating Hamas uh things
that would not have
we're we'll jump to the story from Fox
News this is Federman blast South Africa
genocide case against Israel amid unrest
crime sit this one out so the
interesting thing is he's maybe because
his brain is broken he said when you now
look at what's going on in South Africa
now they should sit this one out and
everyone immediately said in reference
to genocide is he talking about what's
going on with the farmers and of course
there are people who have come up like
no no he's talking about a part hide no
that's not even true I don't know what
he thought he was talking about but his
own statement now is he was talking
about Sudan apparently well I think
they're trying to cover I think he
actually me because he's he said some
pretty like I said he's more based than
a lot of the Republican Senators right
now I mean he he was all for what was it
us steel uh he came out in favor of you
can't get rid of that you can't tell it
I guess it was the Japanese uh he came
out he he's been very pro-israel he's
frankly actually mocked a lot of the
Palestinian uh you know protesters that
started going into to his office and
around that he's come out publicly as a
Democrat senator who a year ago it was
pretty darn woke say like of course we
have to shut down the Border what's
going on there is absolutely insane like
of of course you know so it it doesn't
take a leap based on the actions of even
the last few months to say he was
probably talking about the white
genocide of farmers which again you know
if it's happening to White farmers in
South Africa I guess that's fine
according to the mainstream media today
but it's actually happening it's a real
problem and if we had actual journalists
rather than sort of Dei woke regime
propagandists you know they'd actually
be writing stories about it absolutely
it it's it's fascinating to to see his
kind of development since the poor guy
could could barely speak sometimes it's
almost like the treatment process from
the brain aneurysm actually was like now
he's actually getting better and he's
not espousing the insane policies of the
left that might be the way how you deal
with the woke M virus but I I I I I'm I
find him fascinating ever since he he
came on the political stage I always
said I I want to see him as the VP for
Biden I I literally created bid Biden
fet.my
that was I was crapped on by the
mainstream media over and over again
because like you know when he was
running that campaign and when he became
a I'm like he there were times he was
getting on a stage he forgets where he
is he couldn't form a complete sentence
and he but he'd keep going and it was
clearly like an episode and I I sort of
went after it and people called me an
ableist that's apparently someone who uh
discriminates against those with
disabilities and I was like well I I
just don't think it's an unreasonable
expectation even in this was 2023
America to expect a United States
Senator who's making trillion dollar
decisions Andor could be a deciding vote
in a 50-50 Senate to send our children
to war to be able to have basic
cognitive function yeah if he was a dude
at a restaurant at another table and you
made check out guy at a place I love
that you're gainfully employed I think
that's awesome I'll give you a high five
and respect it like if you're making
trillion dollar decisions if you're
making life or death decisions we should
not be like that how dare you
discriminate again it's like it's it in
no reasonable Society in history now or
in the future would it not be okay to be
like hey man we we just need a a a
reasonable level of cognitive function
to sit there I feel like that with age
it's not age though cuz Biden and and
Don are like similar ages but like it
it's mental cogn cogniance and we got
all these old people and I don't want to
be agist I really don't cuz some people
are 70 even 80 and they're brilliant
brilliant clear thinkers but there's
something too like we got to we got to
talk about these not everyone ages the
same but by the way listen you're not
allowed to talk about looks anymore but
it's the same thing you see people you
know I there's guys I'm 46 there's guys
I graduated college with I'm embarrassed
to tell people like we went to school
together cuz like I like I can't look
like that if I look like that you know
you age differently the same thing
happens with cognitive decline God
willing we all go there longer but I
know guys in their 60s that are a mess I
know guys in their 90s that would run
circles around the average 20 or 30y old
you see it a lot in business like some
of these guys you know they peak in
their 60s and70s business-wise and later
uh you know because they've been able to
sort of learn and grow and get to a
point and then you see you know Joe
Biden I mean my father had a sort of an
interesting he he used to tell me this
story you know ear but he was having you
know conversations like Ted Kennedy back
in the day like Joe Biden was always
known as the stupidest person in the
United States Senate like throughout his
entire tenure there that that that's not
like disputed that's just Senate
understanding now he's also had two
major brain aneurisms I wrote about this
in my book liberal privilege like he's
had things that if you asked you know
let's call it all the same Tes
psychology that said like if my father
grabbed a railing walking down a
slippery ramp he must be in the later
stages of cognitive decline if you ask
those same people honestly and they had
even a modum of intellectual honesty
like no one could go through two brain
aneurisms and and be 100% fine almost
statistically impossible well it depends
on which version of of Biden we're
talking about here as of course a lot of
people watch a video of him 10 years ago
watch a video of him even as VP it's
like it's a different voice it's a
different speed it's like say what you
want there's a decline it ain't the same
yeah I remember talking to him a couple
years ago specifically when he came to
Pakistani isi funding and meetings that
he had uh right before 2001 and uh he he
he was sharp he was quick he answered
right back he was taking questions from
people left and right this was just a
few years ago now the poor guy if it's
even him According to some people who
are saying hey there he's probably
replaced by some kind of other
impersonator uh that's also possible
possible too but but a lot of world
leaders have a lot of impersonators if
you're dealing with someone who can't
walk around or or can't hold their
bowels why wouldn't you use the
impersonator right I it's like Shane
Gill right the Roomba sort of analogy
like Shane Gill and it's perfect like
he's on a stage like I don't I do a lot
of public speaking I get up on a stage I
talk I walk off the way I can't I mean
he gets lost I got I got like canceled
on social because I said well he's
clearly Lo no no no he was uh shaking
hands with someone in the AUD I was like
but the audience was there and he's
pointing 180 degrees from he was clearly
lost whatever they jacked them up with
to give the appearance of you know even
you know temporary Lucidity had worn off
and he's lost but it's not like it
happened once and you forgive it happens
every time you see him speak there's a
reason you know he had nothing on the
schedule today but his you know wife was
on ABC News talking about his great
level of energy he's taken 40% of his
time on vacation as president like there
comes a point in time you have to call
that's why they like he's the
puppet there's a video right now of uh
of trump senior walking out onto stage
for the town hall and he he walks up
stops looks to his left walks a little
bit looks at somebody and they're like
look he got lost and I was like I saw
this claim first a tweet saying Donald
Trump getting lost on the stage says so
much and I was like oh he got lost I was
like I'd like to see this and then I
watched the video I'm like where in this
video does he get lost yeah he made eye
contact with someone was like hey how
you doing right and then he starts
walking doing like an air handshake to
the curtain for seven or eight seconds
remember when he started speaking to the
in backwards so he was on stage and he
was looking at the curtains talking and
everyone's like well how many times have
we seen the headline he walked off the
stage before the ceremony was finished
like he was you know doing something and
giving a ceremony and he shakes hands
and then just walks away through the
middle of the crowd and they're like no
over here how many times have we seen
the video of him you know trying to be
guided into the Oval Office by the
Secret Service because he walks past the
entrance of the office he's occupied for
the last three years I have one word one
word in that sh of pressure yo this is
like this is something where people make
the mistake of of comparing one
president to another president it has
nothing to do with Donald Trump that
dude is sharp his mind is healthy and
clear Biden and Federman we can talk
about in in a little bubble if we want
to what do we do when our
Representatives get messed up in the
head you're supposed to do something
about it but they don't they they won't
because the reality is this the
Democrats listen I honestly whoever is
actually in charge of the Biden admin
whether it's Susan Rice or the Obama or
whatever he's the perfect Fall Guy cuz
he's actually doing all the things Obama
would have loved to have done open
borders pushing the trans crap you
gender surgeries for three-year-olds
that can't make other decisions in their
life but sure you can make that
life-altering decision because they they
wouldn't be willing to destroy their
reputation they wouldn't put that face
in front of the American public they're
happy to throw him under the bus because
he'll sign in you know like he's like
Ron Burgundy put it on the telepromter
say it and it's the gospel he'll sign it
if you if you stick it in front of him
but they could have him do anything in
terms of foreign policy and War and
always just use him as a scapegoat EXA
100% he's just the he's the Fall Guy so
that he's actually for the radical
Democrat agenda been quite effective
because they can actually do the things
that the American public wouldn't let
them get away with do you think it's
Democrat because I think of it as like a
global monetary well but I I sort of
look at the Democrat and a lot of that
sort of world economic forum globalist
you know those ideologies are sort of
the they're not one and the same but
they're blending significantly and thees
uh uh uh view on this is Nikki Haley is
their Inside Job strategy if they can't
defeat Donald Trump at the polls in the
general they'll try and beat him in the
primary with Nikki Hillary yeah well
that that's why I said when there were
people like oh Nikki Haley should be VP
I was like can you
imagine the I don't know if I can curse
the stage in the game but the end curs
guess the M eere that would be going on
from her team trying to subvert
everything that he did from every moment
like it's like so I don't you know what
is it was it
c a f yeah the CIA would get their heart
attack gun out right away and then they
would inst yeah with a or people people
joke like hey Don you should run this VP
because then no one's assassinating your
father I go that's wait a second like
because uh you know but yeah I mean that
it would be a disaster so yeah there's
no question there's plenty of and by the
way like I said with talking about you
know half of the Republicans in the
United States Senate I mean they're not
all that different from the Democrats
Nikki Haley is you know Hillary Clinton
uh dressed up as a conservative for
Halloween like it give me a break like
he wants to be in every war imaginable
sto of big corporate like it it's it's
lunacy at this point do you think that
we can pull the United States back from
being a military government like I feel
like it after World War II basically
reformed our government to become full
militaristic well they're ignoring the
president of the United States whether
it's you know Joe Biden and not letting
him know about Lloyd Austin whether it's
you know you know a like Millie uh
you know but we're we're just not going
to listen to what the President says or
we'll slow playay it so he has ask us
three times and we're just trying to
hope to run out the clock until
something else happens or we create a
scenario if we do this American troops
are going to die well how do you do that
then you must you must you know so you
know there's no question that those
unelected leaders have been trying to
subvert the will of the people for quite
some time uh you know I think maybe the
best thing that Donald Trump ever did be
you know it's not even policy was just
Expos that the Trump derangement
syndrome was so insane that people like
wait a minute like this but it's
actually going on like he brought that
to a light there's no doubt that it was
probably going on way before Trump it's
probably been going on as long as time
but at least he brought it to the light
for the average person to finally get it
the the extreme nature uh you know the
the overcorrection of the pendulum
swinging and the way they're handling
things now is getting people who would
other guys again be politically agnostic
or you just busy trying to feed their
families and not paying attention to
actually listen the the lunacy of the
mainstream media pushing people to watch
you know guys like us right now doing
this uh as opposed to you know taking it
from you know the the Pentagon implanted
stooge at NBC News uh it's making a
difference and I think it's waking
people up we just you know I I I hope we
can uh I hope they don't get to run out
the clock yeah we got to create a vision
of what to do next yeah that's a big
part of the campaign can we Point Alex
Jones as the head of the CIA so I I I
talked about this on my show there's
like I I have a list of like people that
I want to put in positions even for like
a temporary time just so they give you
the guy that you want they Alex Jones is
press sick oror for like just two weeks
uh just just to the shot across the bow
to these guys so uh but you know the
reality say what you want Alex Jones
yeah I'm not saying he's got everything
right he definitely got a couple things
wrong but like he's been more right than
anyone in the mainstream media over the
last 15 years no it's it's and it's not
even close and yet they have credibility
you know the
experts uh you know we Al I Al did this
with like when my dad was dealing with
North Korea and like actually went there
and had a relationship it's like just so
you have a relationship so you know if
crap ever hits the fan you know you can
actually pick up the phone well he's
doing it all wrong he's doing it all
well why well I know because I've been
leading the delegation for North Korea I
like well have you ever met with them no
I can't do that I mean well so you've
been you've been leading the delegation
for like 30 or 40 years but you've never
actually met so you don't actually know
and yet you're an expert like well I
mean we should be revoking expert status
across the board when you have a you
know generational failure uh but that's
not how DC works and Donald Trump made a
lot of progress with North Korea that
was very impressive but then sadly John
Bolton kind of came in and said that
they were following the Libyan model and
kind of literally nuked that larger
peace deal that that Donald Trump could
have had if it wasn't for John Bolton
and I think he gets it done again I mean
I think I think he was you know the he'd
say I had a good Rel relationship with
him he it that doesn't mean he doesn't
understand this is not a good person and
isn't addicted or same with Putin but
what you're supposed to tell Putin to go
f himself embarrass him on a world stage
and know so when something actually does
happen and you do need to make that
phone call you have no Rel like it's
because the experts have never actually
negotiated anything real what do you
think have been some of the biggest uh
learning lessons since the last time
before the question I'm going to do
something I've never done on the show
before I'm going to leave I'm actually
feeling really really sick but we've got
some awesome friends I don't know if
Phil or Josie or or somebody wants to
jump in take my seat why don't you guys
both come up for a minute I'm feeling
real sick bathroom I'm sorry to hear
that I know we try I I tried I got I got
the drink cuz I'm like I just got
punched in the gut hey Phil you want to
sit in for like 10 minutes or so I'm
going to go to the bathroom and listen
to you guys and then I'll come back up
later in the show hey yeah no absolutely
we're but is full transparency I'm like
I hope I didn't piss you off so bad did
I did I disgust you to the point where
uh I'm enjoying it I'm actually I I
resisted for the past 15 20 minutes like
I went up to go to the bathroom I came
back I'm like I can't try try to lay
down try to feel better definely go take
care of yourself we still have super
chats that we're going to be getting
into in about 13 minutes but to kind of
continue the conversation you know a lot
of people still have a lot of questions
specifically when it comes to you know
the military industrial complex or or
big Pharma what would you say has been
some of the biggest learning lessons for
everyone around you specifically when it
comes to the larger realizations of just
how dirty everything is in Washington DC
and what was some of the biggest things
that you've been personally woken to to
just how rotten and bad it is I was
talking about this actually with Josie
earlier so I hate to be repetitive but
we're going to be because no it's really
I you know for me like you wanted as a
patriotic American you wanted to believe
so many of the things that you sort of
you know you know World War II
generation Nostalgia of America and it's
like but now I mean I went through you
know let's call it the opposite of
Hunter Biden right I was guilty of
treason a crime punishable by death
according to the head of the you know
the Intel committees and they were up
there every day and the walls are
closing in and I did 50 hours of
testimony for my life and they altered
my emails that was then proven but each
time you realize like oh my god there
there doesn't actually have to be any
truth to any of the things that they're
saying they they they can get away with
this so you know it was interesting even
as it happened I use sort of the the
general Flynn example a lot you know I
was friends with him on the campaign I
got to know him really well I traveled
with him all over the country I
patriotic American you know they started
going after him I'm like well like it's
that doesn't sound right but like you
know it's the CIA it's the FBI like they
got to be doing you know they got to be
doing they must know something I don't
know and must be you know like so I
didn't come out against them but I sort
of I sat back on the sidelines because I
like well they must know more than me it
turns out it's all like they
don't have to know anything uh they and
they didn't they just create whatever
they want so I I think some I don't want
Nostalgia is sort of not the right word
but sort of that I guess maybe Nostalgia
for an Americana that we want to exist
does not actually exist uh you know
there are people in these positions that
are evil depraved and many of them are
frankly incompetent uh you fouchy is
fouchy was never the best doctor he was
probably never even a good doctor he was
the best mfer you know if someone got in
his way he stabbed them in the back he
was the best at probably manipulating
the Press he was the best at uh creating
obstruction for those who were probably
creating actual real science or doing
really good the GU survived despite
being wrong about everything in the
world since the
1980s uh you know including AIDS
um that's like the predominant makeup of
this sort of Washington DC uh Elite and
the establishment and the people who've
been there for their lives like they
were probably never the best at anything
except being that that mfer that will do
whatever it can to maintain and keep
power uh and that was a scary notion but
I think now that you know that uh now
that you know the players you you got to
do the best you can to actually combat
that but you also have to have the
stomach to actually do that a lot of
people have questions about Dr fouchi
specifically uh with his latest
testimony that he was giving to to
Congress he was playing the fifth a lot
but he also admitted to to essentially
stamping the the approval for for for
something that was extremely dangerous
extremely Reckless that he allegedly
didn't even read himself when it came to
of course sending off Peter dazak the
CIA Echo Health Alliance over to the
Wuhan Institute to work on a particular
sickness that actually um accidentally
somehow also spread in that same city
will there be any kind of uh justice for
Anthony fouchi for all the horrible
things that he did I think I think that
probably has to come through Congress so
you need people to have the balls there
to actually do that I mean if we're
actually going to be you know
constitutional about it but I think
there has to be I mean he he Li I mean
he he bled the fifth on everything he
doesn't remember anything that of
something that happened over the Last 5
Years let's call it but you know he
writes a book about all the great things
over the 20 years prior to that that
doesn't seem to have any lapses in
memory there uh I don't buy that I don't
think anyone else buys that but they
also you know our mainstream media big
Tech they made him a deity I I think I
used the Wuhan sort of lab example uh
you know earlier in the show but I'm you
know I was getting cancelled cuz I was
like well like of course it came from
the lab like what are you talking about
like you're telling me it came from 7 ft
out side of the lab at some wet Market
as opposed to the lab that studies the
exact virus in question but if you were
in medicine you know if you ATT tenure a
university you were canceled if you were
a research person and you said literally
the 100% most plausible answer you lost
your grant money you know again that's
where a guy like a fouchy was you know
he'd wield that power and that money uh
W with an iron fist so you know you got
to do something about it I think Rand
Paul did a great job sort of calling
some of that stuff out but like you know
he was he was infallible according to
the media despite being wrong about
everything but how do you it also at the
time it's hard to go against that
because you know they would have
impeached my father in 30 seconds if he
said wait a second like this is you know
so you know I think as brutal as some of
that was I do hope that you know
people's eyes are opened to you know
just how malicious and just how bad it
actually is and and I think that's an
important First Step uh in actually
taking care of the problem yeah I think
a lot of Americans have been hurt I
think a lot of Americans want Justice uh
but but I I I think one of the issues
that also is kind of a of of a concern
is yesterday during our town hall we had
a member of the US military come up and
ask the first question he was a
gentleman called Drew Drew was was
actually a victim of operation warp
speed um this is sort of a controversial
issue especially now as there's a lot of
questions with Donald Trump's kind of
policies and uh belief systems when it
comes to what transpired and happened
for individuals like Drew out there and
for for the many people who aren't kind
of accounted for and kind of been uh
hurt by this larger operation is there
any kind of recourse or Justice that
could potentially happen for them I I
think there I mean you saw with you know
the military firings and trying to get
those people to back pay and the other
the other you know that was never about
you know forcing that on those people
people could make their own decisions
and then you know uh you try to do that
right I think at the time it would have
been very difficult to go up against uh
to take on F I think you would have been
impeached in about 3 seconds uh if
you're going to be realistic about what
was going on in that uh I think the way
the bureaucracies weaponized a lot of
that was absolutely disgusting and I
think there does need to be
accountability for that there do need to
be I don't want to use the word
reparations but uh you know and it was
strange it it seemed to be Target
against all the people that were
probably more conservative leaning in
the military you know it was the uh The
Operators it was the pilots it was the
this uh it it felt very much to me like
you know a very targeted Purge of those
people who probably a had the most
training but also probably lean more
conservative within the military yeah I
I I think a lot of people also have uh
some kind of significant concerns um
especially let's just say we kind of
move forward here if there's another
situation where there could be you know
potential another quote accidental lab
leak how would uh you guys do things
differently is is I think a question
that I think a lot of people have and
and I think um would love some kind of
clear answers on and then Phil and Josie
feel free to to ask any questions you
guys want as well I don't want to just
to take over I'm going to be doing super
chats in just a little while so I'm just
reading up on those so uh one of the
things that I'm most concerned with um
so should your your dad win like what
are the chance what kind of you know
what are you guys planning on doing to
push back because I I assume there's
going to be all kinds of lawsuits
regardless of what the the actual number
count turns into I imagine there's going
to be endless lawsuits about you know
whether or not your father's the the
accounting was correct and stuff does
does your father have a plan to to to
make sure that the the transition were
to go smoothly and and that does he have
the the the legal power because right
now you know they're going after all the
people you know that's going to be a
factor of it wouldn't matter if my
father's the Republican nominee or not I
mean they they've opened that Pandora
backs they're willing to do that that's
the mark AIA strategy they're probably
doing it before that um and so you know
without question you know probably don't
want to get into details of all those
because they're in in in process uh but
yes I mean I I don't think and again
it's not just about my father I think
there's no question that the Democrats
will do anything that they can to
maintain that power they will there's
nothing they're not willing to bend
break or you know do uh to maintain that
they they've shown that I mean you know
I don't think honestly I don't think
anyone actually believes with a straight
face that you know Joe Biden
outperformed grossly Obama in '08 like
come on uh you know I I think they ALS
they did have the perfect sort of
landscape to get away with a lot more
and get states to sort of throw away
their rights and push even you know
Republicans uh in those States or on
state legislatures just for fear of
being bullied because you know oh oh
you're going to oh you're you're trying
to suppress uh you know the average guy
in a state legislator sure we'll roll
over on our state constitutions uh you
know but you know my father is a federal
he doesn't want to leave those things to
to be decided by the states but the
problem is they were like well we we got
the Republican states it's like no you
basically bullied a couple weak people
in a republican legislator to roll over
and do something that was otherwise
illegal and now you won't reverse it you
see the stuff that they found you know
whether it's Georgia or elsewhere in the
it's like well yeah no it's clear for
all but now now it's it's different now
it's it's already happened so we can't
do anything about it I mean you know
like Wuhan l or the other things like of
course you knew it was nonsense at the
time uh but but we have to combat that
we have to do that with open high I get
a little troubled when I see what are
they talking about virus X today it's
like oh boy here we go again yeah uh you
know you do sort of I you do have to be
prepared because again there's I don't
know that we know what they're going to
do I don't want to just be reactionary
but I don't think you can also plan for
everything because I don't know that
there's any level that their depravity
won't take them that's why a lot of
people have those significant concerns
with what happened in 2020 making sure
that we don't repeat uh where we were
were before and uh I don't I don't think
kind of Donald Trump gave us a clear
answer on that yet but I don't want to
just keep harping on that and just going
into that but but it's it's pretty clear
that there's some kind of outside force
here an outside influence that's very
powerful it's pretty clear uh Joe Biden
really isn't in charge here
um who is who would you say is the
biggest power structure in our
government that has the most influence
has to probably be the Obamas you know
the Obamas you Susan Rice Valerie Jared
it's just that team and that's why Joe
is the perfect you know install it's
like ah the guy will sign whatever we
put he's kind of a guy you know you know
it it was also interesting it's like as
bad as I think he's been for America
disaster you don't hate him right you
could hate Hillary Clinton like it's
really easy to hate Hillary Clinton it's
just like every time she opens her mouth
it's like okay fine like you know uh he
was like you know a big dumb animal like
you don't just kick a big dumb animal
just cuz you know and I I think that was
you know worked perfectly they you know
threw in Camala Harris pulling at 1%
because they could check off a couple
boxes and play the identity politics
game that seemed to be so effective with
uh the nonsense you know I I don't know
that they can get away with it again as
as well simply because people see it uh
you know Joe's safe because the only
person probably significantly worse than
Joe Biden would actually be Camala
Harris because if you've listened to
anything she's said over the last three
years it's like even like people that
like want to they're like oh my like was
it always this bad I'm like yes that was
a great V pick P pick for for Biden that
was a great insurance policy that was
extremely smart for him to do that you
know they'll probably try to figure out
how to you see them slowly like all of a
sudden now the hunter laptop matters now
the bribery stuff matters you know you
see the Democrats sort of trying to work
because they realize that Joe probably
isn't the guy that can take him to the
promised land anymore so but the reality
is there's you know an infinite amount
of you know mination of what these guys
can try to pull and I think you just got
to be ready for all of it because again
I don't think there's a place they
wouldn't go yeah the regime also has a
lot of political prisoners individuals
like Ross oook Julian Assange Edward
Snowden what do you think are the
chances that that someone like Julian
Assange actually could get pardoned
could actually be free since he's not
even an American citizen he's being
charged for for journalism that that
used to be commended and respected here
and and now the United States literally
left him in in jail in solitary
confinement and made him lose his that's
the thing thatal he's not even a US
citizen and and he's on the Run we
actually talked about this last time I
was on the show with Tim you guys
weren't there but uh it's interesting
and you asked about like the things you
do differently like if you asked me like
seven eight years ago uh I W now he a
traitor to our country he I'm like now
I'm like no no no wait wait so he
exposed that we were literally lying to
not just the world but to the American
citizens and so uh in sort of being
being exposed to the insanity and being
you know Snowden similarly perhaps not
quite the same level as Assange but you
know my mentality on that has gone
literally 180 in the last you know again
I don't know the exact timing but
probably seven or eight years where I
would have felt the exact opposite right
now I want these guys out there I I want
you know I I want people who are willing
to go to those lengths frankly to have a
check and balance on you know what what
I believe to be a totally corrupted and
broken regime um a lot of people also
have spe spefic questions we're going to
go to super chats in just a littleit
little bit I think right after this uh
question because we have a lot of super
chats here that I have a lot of very
interesting questions uh but but one
last question the Jeffrey Epstein Saga
yeah um we still don't have any justice
we still know very little I I I I kind
of do believe that it's kind of the
Obamas going after the clintons by this
latest release that we're all seeing
with all the documents kind of coming
out they're trying to subvert their kind
of chances of taking out Biden but
that's just my own personal kind of
speculation and Theory there uh under
the Trump Administration Bill Bart
essentially committed a cover up here he
told us that he was watching the
videotapes there were no videotapes we
were lied every step of the way is there
a plan to get Justice for like the
thousands of children here that were
trafficked that were hurt in so many
unspeakable ways as the the people on
the The Client List have not been named
they're still walking around well there
was allegedly video I mean I've been
pretty vocal about this on Twitter if
you follow me there like I mean like
really vocal because it's it's insane I
mean there's you know this we well
there's another case that alleged that
there's video of Bill Clinton himself
I'm like wait a minute like so there
there is or like there isn't like if
there is and he hasn't yet been arrested
by the FBI uh what's going on and if
there isn't then someone should come out
and say no this is nonsense and I
haven't seen either of those things
happen uh which is truly scary so no
that one's uh insane the fact that they
hit it for so long I mean my my initial
commentary on this was like you know
they've gone through incredible lengths
to actually try to tie my father to
Jeffrey epy for years he threw him out
of marago in the early 90s for suspicion
of stuff like that before anyone really
knew uh what was going on that's not the
story they show one picture of him over
and over again they don't show the
hundreds of Hollywood celebrities and
Democrat Mega donors that visited
Epstein island with them all the time I
I was said I go you know you know
Trump's not on the list because it's the
only list that would have actually
leaked or The Only Name on the list that
would have leaked literally within 0.01
second uh of it being you know ever put
out there but
listen I I think I said it probably two
or three days ago there's got to be
accountability for these people they did
this stuff and that they can get away
with it it there's no to me there's no
worse CRI you the pedophile should be
shot as far as I'm concerned there's no
you know it's it's that uh I it's that
serious but you know just because
they're the elites and they're on these
lists and they're they're they're
getting away with it right now so we got
to do something about it and didn't your
dad ban Jeffrey Epstein yeah no he
literally banned him from marago in like
no like the 9s early he was like
something's off here he kept trying to
like there like weirdo stuff so he's
like I don't know but we heard there was
a real estate dispute between them or or
was it wasn't a real estate can you give
us more information about that I I think
you know it was a little I was probably
12 but uh he was you know it seemed like
he was fairly uh you know coming on to a
lot of very young people that were
hanging around the club and starting at
the club at Mar logo yeah wow you and
then during the first that's not going
to fly over here for then he was banned
and you don't never that's why you see
the one picture that they show it's like
you know my dad looks like he's 25 years
younger because they weren't buddies
they didn't hang out with it but but
again that picture shows up all the time
but not Bill Gates not George
stephanopolous not Bill Clinton going
there 37 times you know often you know
the stories I've read you know without
secret Ser why why on Earth would you
need that Kevin spy Chris Tucker Bill
Richardson all of them basically the
who's who of you know you know Democrat
policy and then it's sort of funny cuz I
and I'm guilty of this one myself it's
like you know then they're like well
step Hawking and then you know the memes
start flying with the wheelchair and
stuff like that I'm like it's like well
is that to distract from the actual
names and I was guilty of pushing it and
he's he happens to be dead so it's like
well that's the guy will throw under the
bus but the guys that are still very
much alive that are still very much at
centers of power within government uh
within Corporate America you know it's
like oh you know we're not going to talk
about them yeah uh so you know yeah no
that that doesn't yeah Sergey Bren a lot
of individuals implicated here Josie by
the way it's only the first part of you
know that my understanding it's only the
first part of the list like it's not
even the names we've seen as big as it
was is not even like there's a lot more
power there I imagine the really most
powerful problem maybe you never even
see because they've been able to figure
it out exactly well there's also
redacted names in the look in the bees
at the redacted names and see what could
possibly fit in there anyway we're going
to jump to Super chats so fitzburg here
says please talk to Don Jr about
graphine I think Ian did that
earlier did it a little bit I mean it
sounds kind of interesting and I love
that yeah you know since China sort of
has taken control of all the rare earth
minerals and copper mines around the
world I love this concept of
conductivity and seems like uh does a
great job undercutting them I I got to
honestly I got to learn a lot more about
it because I don't I don't know all that
much but the in the brief few minutes
that we spoke about it sort of uh sort
of yeah Ian Ian got it out as soon as it
feels like the kind of technology that
China would buy to to quash so that they
maintain their power but uh we got to
make sure that doesn't happen too we
have another Super Chat here from
yanette Santana saying is it true the
reason Epstein galain recruited the
grounds Keeper's daughter from Mar Largo
that I don't know got him that I don't
know jie you want Keith Hansen great
seeing you in Iowa stay warm and come
back when it's warmer sometimes see the
low Hills
cool I'll have to check it out yeah it's
beautiful here honestly it really is
it's cold I don't know if it's beautiful
I'm from Miami I I don't know if you
could call this place the only reason
Jess says that is cuz she's from from
Massachusetts it's not actually
beautiful right now I promise it's
freezing yeah it's it's just it's just
cold although the last time I was here I
was actually hanging out I got in when
we first started the political thing you
know I'm a outdoors guy I'm a Hunter and
all that stuff and uh Terry Branson who
was like the longest serving governor in
the United States he was the governor of
iron they did this like sort of annual
Governor's hunt it was about bring
business in you go out deer hunting and
it was during the like I guess 2015 2016
like polar vortex and I remember sitting
out on a hill and with the windshield
Factor it was minus 57 and you know I
get in because I'm actually into these
things a lot of the other people were
just there for business and everyone
else I guess had come in and the
governor was like like you actually sat
out there that whole time I was like I'm
here in Iowa I got I was able to draw
tags like trying to get some hun get it
in like so you know I guess I earned
some uh some props for probably being
dumb enough to actually subject myself
to the horrors of the Polar V that is a
really good segue into our next Super
Chat from Bob o the thiri it's going to
be so cold that Jesse will need
bodyguards great segue all right let's
see you want to do another one I don't
have them in front of me okay I got them
let me see all right oh we got one from
Kendall bird I'm just seeing the new
ones that are popping up go go from the
you do the ones in the very beginning
I'll do the ones that pop up right now
for me I only have three we got one
asking Don Jr if he would run for office
in the
future you may not have a choice you
know I don't know that I want the day
job right now you know I sort of now I I
do like some of the parts of let's call
it the game because frankly you know
there's a component of it that is even
though the stakes are pretty serious uh
you know I I'm not afraid to sort of be
out there I'm not afraid to fight I'm
not afraid to do a lot of the things
that so many of the guys in in the
Republican Party are like no we won't do
that we W so you know I don't know that
I want the day job I don't know that I
want to be one of you know 435 people in
Congress or something like that
initially I don't know that I could just
jump right into you know the presidency
or whatever I think my father's kind of
unique in that way but uh you know the
more I do this the more I you know sort
of understand that we need more people
from outside of that sort of government
you know entrenched bureaucracy whose
turn it is who just you know who don't
need it uh maybe who don't even want it
but they're just doing it for the right
reasons and so you never know I never
want to shut it out but you you you do
have to want the day job part not just
sort of you know the the combative part
because you know unfortunately there is
a lot of that stuff you have to deal
with I agree uh Mr Barefoot Blue Jean
says five years prison terms for anyone
hiring illegals if they can't work
they'll stop coming you know actually
something interesting the articles of
the Constitution are actually silent on
immigration the federal Authority is
limited to uh naturalization laws so the
10th Amendment says that all undelegated
rights they're reserved for the state
so or respectively the people so he's
right and uh the Biden regime has no
authority to mess with Texas so if y'all
didn't know that it's a it's a state's
thing the Border um and until it comes
to inv it should be but then the problem
is they say well if you don't do this
we'll cut off all your other funding for
this now you no longer have roads and
you we no longer have you know it's
blackmail yeah it is by the way the
whole thing is an extortion scheme right
oh yeah absolutely that's the entire
Department of Transportation that's how
they get the you know yeah comp from all
kinds of of different ordinances that
they they want to pass can we get Ron
Paul um a head of the Federal Reserve is
that
possible get get ran to be the uh vice
president maybe all right uh MZ Kim 1223
says along with deportation arrest and
find people who employ illegals make it
very difficult for them to get jobs
employers need to be held accountable
they they they like the illegal
immigrants they can work for nothing
yeah that that's the I mean the problem
is there's a lot of hey you know we
we've always had to be careful because
we're sort of out there in the public
eye and everyone's trying to sue us and
throw us in jail for everything but I
mean you know we run golf courses and
hotels and you know the average guy
doing those things is oh yeah like it's
a lot easier to pay cash off the books I
mean you saw a lot of this uh you know
even beyond the illegals just with some
of the welfare and incentive programs
you know there's a lot of people you
know that I know that that ran small
businesses and being from you know the
real estate background and construction
trades like people would they'd quit
they'd work 3 days a week off the books
they'd take their unemployment they were
net ahead by 30% of what they were doing
in in an otherwise even reasonably
well-paying job you know and everyone's
gaming that system so you know I I I I
conceptually it's a great idea but I
think yeah yeah uh let me see Polly
puree says Tim get well oh and then
right beneath that free men free men Die
free says CIA poison Tim disease x super
spreader event everyone every you think
that they they gave you think they
poisoned Tim because he's talking with
me you know every everyone in the
comment section just telling me that
that I put laxatives in his drink I
didn't put laxative in his drink uh
there's another Super Chat here from
James Richard saying ask junor why the
first time in America lockdowns occurred
under Trump if this was the Deep State
how would it be different this time
around again I think you we we we've
seen what was going on at the time I
think to be you know you got to be
realistic you know everything you can
look back on and say oh you should you
know at the time if if you didn't listen
to Anthony fou you don't think that the
Congress would have impeached him 100%
you know everyone in the media would
have pushed it they so you know I think
we've learned from that I think my
father did leave all of those things to
the states and you I think you saw a big
difference uh between you know sort of
conservatives and and liberals in in how
that handles and there's also been quite
you know quite a bit of revisionist
history in in uh even the way a lot of
the conservatives handle those things
but you know I I do think it was sort of
a you know a black Swan event that
people just didn't know and are you
actually Killing American citizens you
know initially and then you know once
once you slowly start figuring that out
uh you can handle it Accord I don't
think anyone's going for that ever again
I think that's probably out of the
Playbook except for when you see again
the world economic Forum talking about
you know disease X because you're like
uh yeah I guess they could try it again
just hoping to run a similar Playbook I
just don't think that anyone in America
would fall for the 10th Amendment was
the fail safe written into the
Constitution the nth and the 10th
Amendment and those were those were the
fail safe for if we ever had a
tyrannical government again they're
going to have to have 50 tyrannical
governors in order to make our country
tyrannical again so we saw that come
into effect during covid we saw um
Governors like you know Dan santis was
pretty good uh South Dakota governor was
great you know um and they weren't they
weren't caving to the the suggestions of
the federal government so that's that's
something good to know we have another
Super Chat from Matthew Hammond saying
how are we going to deal with the NGO
that are facilitating illegal
immigration yeah I mean it's sort of
it's actually sort of amazing because
you see some of them you know link to a
church and they're doing this but I'm
like they're they're they're doing the
trafficking that we're talking about it
so you know I I
think this was the other one where sort
of the acman thing has been interesting
right they're pointing out where you
know these guys have been funding some
of this stuff that they don't even
realize the full you know it's they feel
like they're doing good but then you
actually look into what these
organizations are actually doing the you
know on paper it's great and they give
you a beautiful award but what's going
on again I think we have to expose so
much more of what's actually happening
and then you know you got to put
pressure on people to be able to just
you know stop funding that there these
guys you know the harpst strings have
been pulled you know for all over the
place and sort of the uh you know the
the creation of uh you know the these
Charities as being infallible and so
everyone wants to donate so that they
too can get public acknowledgement and
you know award for not really doing much
but for using their name to show up at a
rubber chicken dinner um you know I
think we got to just call out as much of
it as we can yeah I agree and we got to
stop funding it we I mean but there
needs to be an appetite for people
people have to understand that and they
have to actually just stop doing it but
well you say you say an appetite but I
mean we've already had I think we
fielded like three or three questions so
far about immigration I get it but
there's got there's got to be an
appetite from the other people that are
making laws and the people in Congress
and stuff you I we can all agree uh
together but we need to put pressure on
the people who are actually making those
decisions to do that definitely uh this
next Super Chat from Alan Sher I'm sorry
I said your name wrong Josie in a beanie
next demonic
calendar that's a personal one uh Phil
if you want to get out your phone and
look for some of demonic yeah got quite
demonic we got another I took down Jenna
Ellis so we got a super chat from Lurch
685 saying in his second Administration
I hope Trump is more fair to the
Palestinians now that he realizes
Benjamin Netanyahu isn't interested in
peace or a deal yeah it definitely
doesn't seem like there's a
um a good relationship between Benjamin
and uh and
Donald yeah no I you know I I mean we
sort of beat that one you to death
earlier um but no there isn't but uh you
know I I don't know there there there's
a lot with that one uh there's a lot
with that one you know much of a
terrible but you know also very nuanced
uh Joe a says Jor is great and get well
soon
Tim thank you most people hate my gut at
least on social media that's it's it's
an over representation yeah no it's it's
fine by the way it doesn't matter it's
sort of you know I I sort of enjoy it
like uh Patricia swisser says get better
quickly Tim a these are so
nice I have another one from Heath
Hansen saying please ask Trump Jr if
Land Reform or measures to stop land
hoarding examples Bill Gates Black Rock
Etc are on the agenda you know I I don't
know it's a little I mean maybe I'll
defer to Josie constitutionally you know
if you're an American citizen should you
not be able to buy I mean listen I'm I'm
a very big skeptic of the guy trying to
grow fake meat buying up all the meat
farms and like you know while preaching
climate and talking about cow farting
you know destroying the future of the
world I mean you'd be a moreon not to uh
you know that said I don't know that I
love the idea of banning that either
right I mean the exact question I was
reading these the exact question was if
there's going to be anything done about
Black Rock and Bill Gates buying up all
the land every you know interesting
story so Thomas Jefferson is the reason
why we have property taxes when he was
over in France he saw how they were
dealing because when America was was new
they were dealing with people hoarding
properties they were dealing with them
hoarding land and not cultivating it so
Thomas Jefferson saw that when they were
doing that in France they issued they
did the property tax and this this
prented you know normal people people
from being able to hoard land but now
we're at a point where there's
billionaires hoarding land so so it's
it's beyond that so I mean I guess the
right thing to do would be to abolish
taxes start over
that's fine with this it's not working
I'm not sure I'm getting anything out of
my tax dollars and I know I read a
pretty big check every year I don't know
if you're familiar with the story but
Bill Gates on National Television kind
of bragged about how Donald Trump wanted
to make him a science adviser I don't
know if that's true or not or if that's
just Bill Gates lying to the general
public since of course he's also on a
lot of lists that are are very curious
and he's also working on a lot of really
weird projects that I think are very
questionable I I was involved you know
at least peripherally in the transition
process and stuff like that I never I
never saw that so I don't I don't know
that yeah I don't I don't believe that
to be accurate so uh Robert Clark has a
question about uh FICO scores he asked
will your father reform FICO so us lower
middle class SL uper poverty have a
fighting
chance I mean you know another one that
I I don't really know I mean you know
there's a lot that needs to be done
there you know whether it's F scores
whether it's interest rates whether it's
this I mean it it is seemingly designed
to make that you're talking about Black
Rock I'm I'm more concerned about Black
Rock buying up all the residential
housing in America and and forcing
everyone to be permanent renters and
once they control a uh a a big supply of
that uh because they still need to
generate money with the land so I don't
think they're just as funds they're just
buying land to not have cows on it uh
maybe they're more evil than that but uh
and you know I am more concerned about
them buying up all the housing uh
controlling a you know a big enough
portion of that market jacking up rents
and basically making everyone have no
choice but to do that you know they they
clearly you see you know the
manipulation within the fed the insanity
there you know they're going to try to
lower interest rates a little bit to
make it seem like Joe Biden is doing a
good job to push some of these things
down I think that'll still screw up
inflation but like you know there
there's a lot of complexity
you see you know the gamesmanship
beinged they get to you know the J
numers you know look at the job numbers
are great then we rev them two months
later and well they were never actually
great but they've done this 11 out of 12
months uh you know or or 12 reporting
Cycles I guess and it's like wait a
minute like when are we just why don't
you just give us the real number stop
lying to us it's clear you're trying to
create that narrative that that
incentive so uh I I think there's a lot
that needs to be done within these
systems to make it fair for the average
American uh but you know there are still
you unfortunately I don't think you can
do everything just to to do that without
creating a lot of the stuff that we
would like to avoid yeah there's one
here I don't know if somebody wants to
check on this real quick reports are
coming in this is sorry mat g g Jones
reports are coming in that Iran has
bombed a US Embassy and has hit a US
naval ship with surfac to surface
missiles if somebody wants to check on
that I I can okay oh my I want to say
thank you to uh bis Smith Ian what was
it subel ail
it this Smith it it makes your stomach
feel better ah okay I'm so glad you're I
needed like what was it like 10 minutes
to for the you know was this like a
scene from like the dumb and dumber
toilet scene Tim like the legs up in the
air I I bought a portrait of that just
like yesterday oh really it's one of my
favorite like examples of like I'm he
was yelling at the P my wonderful
girlfriend patting me on the back while
I was washing my hands hunched over and
then after a few minutes start to feel
better I think I know what it is I had
deep fried chicken skin today o it was
the most delicious thing I've ever had
but it's made was it with seed oils I
have no idea I'm sorry you seed oils I
had that once I I you know I like sort
of food from all over the world and I
had that once in India where I got a
little uh adventurous and I I guess I
must have disobeyed some of the rules
there and yeah it was like three days of
of of that reenactment of that scene
that was kind of brutal like someone saw
me a week later like a buddy saw me a
week later and they're like dude are you
okay you look you look literally green I
was like it's been a long that was one
of the most famous videos ever that
dumad dummer scene that uh always kind
of replays in my mind as well turbox
exactly it's absolutely incredible we
got another Super Chat here by Kalen
Shaw indie game saying please ask if we
finally get alien
disclosure it it sort of feels like
haven't we done that now like I it it
does feel like it's the shiny object
like the rest of the world is falling
apart so they're like hey guys there's
aliens everywhere and honestly people
are cares no no one cares everyone's
like I don't know I got other stuff to
worry about it's so much worse than that
it's you're 100% right no one really car
I uh you know it was funny back in I
actually had my father just we did a
thing for like the campaign like back in
like 2020 or whatever and I was like
it's the only thing I want to know and
and he was like you sort of made a joke
about it whatever it was but it was
legitimately the only thing I want to
know um and now it's like it's pretty
clear we have these sightings they're
releasing it and like I no longer care
because like there's like real stuff to
worry about the aliens are coming here
they see who's leading us they're like
it's not worth it is it is it aliens or
is it interdimensional beings as Tucker
Carlson has even come out and said that
the government made a deal with some of
these interdimensional beings as well is
there anything potentially that you
could even tell us about that I or is it
classified yes I'm GNA go with it's
classified because I have no idea we're
dealing with demons aren't we I think
it's talking plasma which is where they
take lasers from base stations and they
triangulate them in the air creates a
ball of plasma they can move around like
a laser pointer a lot of it's when
they're like how can a craft move like
that spe drun I've always been sort of a
believer in Aliens only just cuz like
how could you not with the just the the
vastness of the univer like we're we're
the only ones like no you know maybe
it's more advanced than us but like just
statistically playing out something
that's essentially infantes large like
there's probably someone and there's
probably someone more advanced than us
and there's probably plenty of things or
whatever that are less advanced than us
but I don't know there has to be yeah we
when uh you weren't on the show but we
pulled up talking plasma and I can't
remember it was last week or whatever
and we showed the video of how they do
it talking it's where they use multiple
lasers have them all intersect in so you
point two three lasers and it don't
cross beams like just like Ghostbusters
like yes when the lasers cross it
creates a a ball of light and you can
move it around at the speed of light so
theoretically if you get 100,000 of
these lasers you can project a
threedimensional image in space and have
it move around at the speed of light
people will think it's aliens or
something when it's just a light show
how do you move it at the speed of light
though wouldn't it be limited to how
fast you could move the laser which you
you you move it to the light is fast I
so it's it's you know the lasers move a
little bit but the exponential speed
increase based on the you know the GU
far enough away I guess you could create
an arc that gets right it looks like
it's moving super fast and stopping and
then starting interesting we got another
Super Chat from Jeremy Hammond saying
Don Jr what's your opinion of Bitcoin
and the newly approved ETFs Jeffrey
Jeffrey Hammond I was just going to read
po we're both interested yeah you know I
don't know enough about the ETF I saw
obviously you know launched um you
listen I I I love anything that's not
sort of controlled by the central
government at this point so I like the
concept of it I I imagine it's being
infiltrated and they're doing whatever
they can and you see all the you know
the governmental linked ones I'm like it
sort of defeats the purpose of why I
like it uh you know I it's why I keep my
you know 1970 Toyota J because there's
not a chip that they can just shut it
down and I figured the government you
know whether it's our government or
other governments you know if the
Chinese are hacking the Pentagon they
could probably figure out how to you
know get into the blockchain and I
understand it's you know very
complicated but there's probably guys
that can do that and so you know I I I
love the concept of it because I I just
have so little faith in actually our own
governments and our own currency right
now uh let's see Raven G Stanley Jr says
shout out to the travel team of IRL
smooth shows that's nice thank you
that's surge in case you're wondering oh
Kell's too we got another Andrew out
here for all the stuff they set up oh
yeah Mosaic is a big shout out too for
all the stuff they set up yes shout out
keep your
bartender I'll let me
see I have another one here from Cedric
Stanley saying Don any chance you could
talk Luke into tell telling his T-shirt
people to give us an option to have the
printing on the back so I can buy a
hoodie no that won't happen all on on
the best political shirts.com uh let me
see Colin D says Congress and Senate are
the problem how do we get term limits
passed on the people who have to vote to
limit
themselves you just answered it yeah it
it ain't G to H you you really got to do
is you got to vote people in there who
you know who don't need the job you know
again you know the guys Thomas Massie
doesn't need the job yeah well you know
a JD Vance in the Senate guys like that
guys who've accomplished stuff in the
outside world they're going to go in
there they can fix you know if you get
the entire makeup of Congress to be
those people you you won't actually be
concerned about term limits because
they'll actually do the right thing um
and so you know I think it's so
important we do you know we talk
obviously you know for me biased it it's
a presidential race but like you know
the reality man there there's times I
when I see what's going on in the world
like I'm more concerned about like
running for your school board than I am
running for congress or running for
Senate it's like I think we could
actually probably uh affect more
change uh you know eliminating that
indoctrination at the lowest levels of
government rather than the highest and
sort of going the other way through
there so you know we we got to get
involved in all of these things it's a
bottomup approach that's going to fix
the country I mean the Communists for
all of their disgusting awful unhuman
things that they do they know how to
infiltrate a government and they did it
from a bottom up approach and that's the
school boards Sheriff's Department
select boards and they work their way
into the state and then into the federal
and then into every leadership and every
institution in our country and that's
that's how we beat them by their own
tactics if we did a uh Convention of
States because that'd be another way to
get terms passed bypass Congress we
convene what I don't know 39 of the
states or 32 33 would that be that 11
are we 11 states short on that now or is
it less now eight states mentioned
that's a big Pandora's Box you might not
want to open because you can change a
lot of laws they can get in there Second
Amendment yeah but you can't BRS though
you can you can set a rules that that
these are the only things that are
actually on the docket for the
convention so
I just sort of feel like the other side
has weaponized sort of the that stuff so
well that I think they'd probably do it
better than us and they'd figure out a
way to do it again and eliminate those
rules and fair enough you know I just I
don't know that I've trust our
leadership enough to actually do these
things right and not just to get rolled
I mean you know yeah I would I would
hope for I'd love to believe it
conceptually but you like that's my big
one or one of my biggest problems with
the with the Republicans now is finding
really good competent leaders I don't
feel like that just like you were
talking earlier it's not a deep uh deep
well of of leaders that you can actually
look to on the conservative side that
are actually you know America First and
qualified to actually run yeah no that's
correct there's a there's a couple guys
that are really good with sound bites
that have no chance of actually getting
anything done there and I I sort of I
see this a lot it's sort of like the no
but if we just did this person to be
great I like yeah but that's just not
ever going to happen in DC like we we we
actually still have to play
within the realm of reality so you know
we always have our wish list but like so
much has to happen before you could ever
even possibly think about this wish list
but we we get obsessed about y it's just
this guy you know and then that guy gets
some power you realize he's just get get
rolled and fail and like you know yeah
you know hey I think we see some of that
going on right now with the speaker of
the house it's GNA be that this is a
good segue actually uh true the new it's
get me so much better it's like is it
inspirable support says Dawn who is your
top selection for your dad's VP key he
said it we we already answered this
question oh well this was asked well I I
think I think I mean we said it sort of
out of the I mean I talked about like
you know liking a lot of what viic is
saying out of the sort of the people
that were running yeah uh you know I
think there's other people that would be
great out I mean I've mentioned a JD
Vance something like that there's uh you
know there's definitely you know a
couple people like that it's a small
group you know it's that that could be
great in those positions I like the idea
of a bulletproof best I mean the way
that it would normally go is he tried
not to alienate the people who hate him
and get somebody safe like like a Mike
Pence or a Mike Johnson so Mike Pence
made sense in 16 because you needed to
sort of balance out you needed a yin and
yang like I know that you need that
anymore you know Donald Trump wasn't the
dictator that they said Joe Biden is far
far more of a dictator or a fascist than
anything uh you know Trump ever was you
know I think that sound B they're
desperately trying to do that again but
like you know I don't know that it plays
as well as you know they think it does
anymore because you have four years to
look back on let's get one more in there
we got one from Ryan lelli saying what's
your opinion on the solution to the
Ukraine
war cut off the money it's the only way
you get them to the table right as as
long as I mean we're literally creating
the oligarch class of billionaire in
Ukraine with whatever is being siphoned
off whether it's zinsky whether it's
this while they send young men to die as
Canon fodder on the front lines because
they couldn't care less it's
disgusting what's going on there uh that
it's allowed to happen that we shut down
anything it's so obvious nothing's ever
going to change there if the money keeps
flowing my father would have been like
hey you got like one more month of this
and if you're not at the table it's done
guess what zalinski wouldn't have a
chance if we shut it down so he'd come
to the table and they'd come up with
something absolutely I that it like it's
so ridiculous that we're in the second
year of this thing uh that you've had
you know countless lives lost on all
sides but like you know the press the
Ukraine are they're winning they shot a
Russian tank you know meanwhile they had
a strategic withdrawal from the Damas
region I'm like wait a minute so they
withdrew from like a quadrant of the
country but they shot a tank or you an
armored personnel vehicle and they're
winning like they were never
winning they were never winning they
were probably never going to win but as
long as we kept feeding them infinite
money dragging out prolonging the effort
all we've done is kill hundreds of
thousands of innocent men half of whom
were probably indifferent to some of the
politics CU they were ethnically Russian
anyway like it's disgusting what's going
on there right now and it's going to
keep going as long as we're basically
writing checks you know taking care of
them uh with no
accountability uh you know no tracking
of the money no tracking of the weapons
I
mean it's insane it's insane and you
know again I I've been very vocal about
this one for for quite some time you
know and you knew it was going bad when
my father did this the first CN in town
hall he was like Hey man all I want is
like the death to stop how dare you I
mean you don't want to kill every living
Russian like I'm like like what is going
on here like that was like the per like
even guys like Joe like that was like
the perfect answer is the only answer
frankly and you know that war machine
you know they you know we hadn't been in
a war in like you know a year since
Afghanistan so like you know it was time
they got to get that thing cranking back
going absolutely I I couldn't agree with
you more uh I think we're already over
time this was a really interesting
podcast this was really fascinating
thank you so much for for coming down it
was awesome uh if people want to find
out more about you if people want to
check out your website what would be
that website where can they support you
uh you know on most of the social media
platforms on truth on Twitter
donaldjtrump jr.com you know
donaldjtrump Jr I got a uh my triggered
podcast is on rumble on Mondays and
Thursdays at 6 p.m. check that out live
I you know have these conversations I do
a lot of the same sort of like ask me
anything you know quite often on and or
have other guests you know often
politics but other stuff uh you know if
you like my outdoor stuff you can follow
us over the field ethos Journal uh sort
of have a cool sort of unapologetic sort
of outdoor witty good writing you know a
little bit of everything thank you so
much for taking our questions and uh Tim
where where can people find you well
Luke promised to discuss something that
was not so familyfriendly in the members
only uncensored show and you you had
pointed out very early on we can talk
about that right so we'll talk about
that oh yeah t-shirts Epstein a few
other things so head over to
timcast.net
remains on Twix I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music uh Pandora YouTube
you know the internet yeah I guess we
put up our stuff on on Spotify and you
know iTunes podcast as well my podcast
there so you know you're driving yeah
triggered if you know you can check it
out there too rock and roll me and
crossin what's happening catch you guys
later peace I am Josie the redheaded
libertarian you can find me on X trhl
official you can also check out my show
which is spaces with Josie and it
streams on X and also on timcast.net
we're growing there very fast if we
reach 100K Clint Russell gets tasered
it's going to be a lot of fun we're
almost there we could get there right
now with you guys just subscribing to
the best political show.com Clint is
watching right now he's not really happy
this was a great show Tim I hope you
feel better are we still doing the after
show we are doing the after show stay
tuned for the after show on timcast.net